Four,
three,
two,
yes.
Rob.
Hello.
What's up buddy?
You look great man.
You look super healthy.
O' lakes when you're doing your mill.
I know you're doing a lot of Jujitsu but
you look leaner and I her and they took
the pineal gland out of a small child
and then implanted in me.
Is that all you need to do?
Pretty much judging.
If that was the case,
you'd people would run around with
helmets on their kids illegal here.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
yeah.
Where'd you go to get it done?
I can't really divulge that.
Oh cool.
Cool.
Yeah,
we'll.
Wherever it was.
As long as he wasn't America.
Right?
Right.
So,
uh,
you're,
you're balls deep in Jujitsu these days,
man.
Trying to.
Yeah,
but you could see that in you.
Like you look different.
You really do.
You look like when I was on here last
time I was at the end of a pretty big
travel cycle,
like doing military gigs and stuff like
that and that was pretty beat down and
we've had two kids since,
I think I was on the podcast and older
that has beat me down to beat me down in
a different way.
So I've just been at home and I can
train,
don't travel as much.
And so yeah,
everything's been pretty good.
I do this gymnastics bodies programming
couple of days a week,
a little bit of squatting,
a little bit of dead lifting pretty on
point with food and then just getting
the dog Piss beat out of me at jets,
like two to four days a week.
So yeah.
Yeah.
What got you into that?
Oh Man,
I've always been interested in martial
arts.
Like as a kid I had a brown belt and
like the Ed Parker Kenpo system.
Old School.
Yeah.
Old Old School Elvis Presley style.
Yes.
And uh,
and you know,
like I knew that Parker had some
connections with like Bruce Lee in jkd
and I was really always really
interested in that.
So I went down to Long Beach,
California and ended up tracking down
some folks at the Inosanto Academy and,
and sparred with a kid that had been
doing tai boxing for like six months and
he was 60 pounds lighter than I was,
not particularly athletic.
And he beat the crap out of me.
I mean it was just like a man fighting a
boy.
Only I was bigger and stronger and
faster and he just destroyed me.
So I went back home and I burned my
brown belt and I started studying some
Thai boxing and it wasn't long after
this that I encountered Brazilian
Jujitsu for the first time and I had a
little bit of a high school wrestling
background and I was a state county,
the California state power lifting
champion.
So strong athletic kid.
And again,
like this guy like submitted me 50 times
in like two minutes.
And I was just kinda blown away.
But this was back in like [inaudible] 92
when,
unless you were in a major metropolitan
area,
you just couldn't find Jujitsu,
so I did a couple of weeks of it then
you know,
around like 92 93 and I didn't have a
second Jujitsu session until like 2003
and again it was like a month or
something because at that point the
folks that we're usually running these
schools,
like they could barely keep 'em open.
They were like 9:00
in the back of a karate school or
something.
Right.
So it's only been the past couple of
years that I've been able to be pretty
consistent.
So you just found a great gym out where
you were at?
Yeah,
yeah.
I've kind of bounced around a little
bit.
Kelly farrel,
conviction,
martial arts,
and then also the gorilla Jujitsu
affiliate there in Reno.
And then I get out to Elko to the guys
that a straight blast gym in Elko under
Chris Meyer.
So you out in the Reno area?
Yeah.
I didn't know what Rena was like.
I went to Reno this past August and
went,
I've maybe had passed through once when
I was younger,
but we went through reno into the
mountains in Nevada.
It's fucking beautiful.
It is.
It is,
yeah.
It's four seasons.
Like the summer's great winter was
really cool this year.
Good snowboarding and all that.
So it looks like a Colorado up there,
like,
do you think Nevada you think desert,
you think barren landscape?
Not Very pretty or pretty in those sort
of a like,
hey,
you better bring water sort of a way.
It wasn't like that at all.
It was gorgeous.
Yeah.
Um,
it's kind of funny when people,
you know,
like if I'm being interviewed or
something too,
like you live in Reno really?
Is that part of a parole violation or
something that I really liked it.
The thing that is sad though is the
casinos in Reno,
they're weird.
It's,
it's a really weird mix because you have
like Tesla and all these tech companies
that have moved into town and it's
really got this new vibe going on.
Yeah,
like the big tesla mega plant is out
there kind of east of town,
so you've got this kind of technology
scene,
there's a whole startup row in downtown
Reno and then you have the casinos and
that whole underbelly element to it.
And so these two things are like
literally,
you know,
you change corners downtown and you're
in either the lake super depressing,
you know,
like failed at the casino deal or you go
around the corner and there's a bunch of
guys with the technology startups,
technology startups will overwhelm the
shitty casinos.
I still,
you know,
like tech in general and this is maybe
getting off in the weeds,
but there's so much stuff that's just
been built on speculation and eyeballs
and nothing real that I'm still curious
if like tech in general is going to make
it.
So yeah.
It's uh,
how so in what way do you know,
you know,
there was so much speculative money that
went into that scene and the,
you know,
there's only a few entities like
facebook and Google and stuff that have
really turned it into a money making
venture.
And a lot of these technology startups,
there was a lot of money going into
them,
but it was just kind of predicated on
growth or eyeballs,
but they never really had a strategy
towards profitability.
And so I'm just kinda curious how many
of these things are really gonna gonna
make the cut.
But it could be really good to like if
we,
if that stuff tightens up and people
really start looking at it like a
legitimate business and not just
eyeballs and bandwidth.
So it'll be interesting.
Yeah.
I've always thought that was weird about
twitter.
The twitter
has so many users and has so much.
There's so much activity,
there's something going on there.
Right.
But then they have to figure out how do
you generate money from that.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
It's worth a lot of money,
but for no reason.
Right.
It's like God,
everybody's using it.
Yeah.
But what do you do with it right
now?
But I feel like someone's going to
figure it out,
but I felt like that two years ago.
Right.
You know?
Yeah.
They stay open.
I have no idea.
Like,
uh,
yeah,
I don't know.
I keep hearing that I'm on a shadow
banned list.
You heard of that?
I don't believe it.
I think it's horseshit.
We have Jordan Peterson on,
so that probably got you on some sort of
a short latest.
I've got a bunch of people on Gavin
McInnes is more egregious probably and
more ridiculous.
And uh,
Steven Crowder,
Alex Jones is the biggest one for sure.
Right.
Did you see what the list like means
like what it means to be on that list?
No,
not exactly.
Like you just get your tweets reviewed
by a person before they make it out to
your feet or something like that out of
here.
Really?
Is that real?
That's what it said.
I don't know if it's real,
but that's what it said
most of my tweets and make it out there
and the ones that don't.
Thank you.
Thank you for cut those off because it
was some kind of oversight.
I'm hammered at the comedy store at 2:00
in the morning.
I want to rile people up for no reason.
So yeah,
thank you for protecting me from myself.
I'm kidding.
I'm not in any way advocating censorship
and I don't,
I'm not,
I'm not necessarily sure.
I believe it either.
Sorry about that.
Deviation of.
Not at all.
Yeah.
So I've been following your instagram
feed and uh,
you and your wife have been doing some
crazy blood sugar tests after foods,
postcard meals,
like beans and a bunch of other
different high carb foods.
What are you trying to do there?
Are you on a Keto diet or what are you
doing?
I generally run really well.
Quito or pretty close to it.
I'm fueling Jujitsu is a little rough
with that.
So I maybe do about 75 to 100 grams of
carbs on harder training days.
And then other days it's pretty low
carb.
My wife though is kind of like
Wolverine,
like you just can't kill her.
And this is some of the stuff that I've
learned in the past couple of years,
this personalized nutrition where
there's a huge variation from person to
person and how they respond to
carbohydrates,
foods in general,
but in particular carbohydrates.
There was a study done at the Weizmann
Institute in Israel a couple of years
ago and they basically put a continuous
glucometer on folks.
It's a little disk that you pop on the
back of your arm.
They did a full genetic screen on them,
a gut microbiome test,
and then they started feeding these
folks different meals and the blood
glucose responses were all over the
place.
Like one person would eat rice and they
would have a barely perceptible blood
glucose increase and another person
would be near diabetic from,
from beating that Rice.
And do they believe this is a genetic
variability?
Is that location like where their
genetic ancestors and gut microbiome
seem to drive it?
And so if the gut is unhealthy,
then that seems to make your blood sugar
response worse.
And then conversely,
if you eat in a way that makes your
blood glucose response look pretty good,
then the gut microbiome seems to shift
towards what they consider to be a
healthier profile.
Huh.
So now is there anything you can do to
your Gut biome to change the glucose
profile?
Yes.
Um,
what exactly what to do is pretty
complex.
Like,
you know,
some people can have a condition called
small intestinal bacterial overgrowth
where the bacteria are basically growing
too far north in the gut essentially.
And then whenever you eat something with
carbs in it,
it makes those bacteria grow in an
inappropriate place in inappropriate
way.
And it's Kinda difficult to basically
starve the bacteria in the fore gut and
then feed the bacteria in the hind gut.
And there are some,
some,
yeah,
Chris Kresser on like,
he's one of the best people in the world
probably in dealing with stuff like
that.
But it's,
um,
uh,
I'll put it like this in the last five
years,
we've learned more about the gut
microbiome than we knew in the previous
50 years.
And like literally every month that goes
by we will learn more and more and more.
But the clinical application of doing
something to help somebody that's sick
is not easy.
It's a pretty complex process.
A lot of people will experience a lot of
improvement from just kind of a low carb
diet,
but it doesn't work for everybody.
Like they may a lot of people may need
like some herbal interventions like a
garlic in and different antimicrobial
agents that help to knock that bacterial
overgrowth back.
And it's a,
it's a pretty challenging process.
Particularly if the person is really
sick.
Does fasting have any effect on it?
It can.
It can just like reduced meal frequency
seems to improve the gut microbiome and
in the overall gut health.
So this is some of the stuff that I
think is going on with intermittent
fasting where instead of eating like six
or seven meals a day and just constantly
kind of keeping the gut inflamed instead
doing maybe one or two meals a day.
Pretty broad spacing seems to have some
great benefits for folks.
I've been doing that thing where you
only eat for 10 hours a day.
Yeah,
yeah.
I did a podcast with Dr Rhonda Patrick.
She was explaining it to me and I said,
let me give it a try and I've had some
really great results.
I lost a lot of body fat almost
immediately.
I started losing body fat from it,
but didn't lose any energy and don't
feel great.
I mean,
it just,
everything feels really good.
But uh,
it's been,
it's challenging because I would come
home from shows like late at night and
I'd be hungry.
Right.
And I'm supposed to be drinking water,
like,
you know,
he was supposed to have anything that
your body has to metabolize,
right?
Yeah.
Even coffee will kind of cause a little
bit of a adrenal response.
The liver kicks out some glucose and
then it basically presses the reset.
But what about herbal tea?
I would think that that would probably
be okay,
but I mean,
the folks that really know a lot about
it,
like Rhonda Patrick Valter,
Longo,
they're really pretty adamant that in
that fasting period,
like just wanting nothing but water.
Yeah.
Water is delicious when you thirsty,
but not so good for the rest of the
time.
You're like,
oh,
it's boring ass.
Well,
that's why I grabbed one of these guys
are real.
He is.
Yeah.
Via for people don't know is not a
sponsor.
It's just we drink it and it's Stevia
flavored soda,
so it's really like a guilt free soda.
Right?
Which is crazy.
Like soda that's sweetened with plants,
right?
And not sweetened in a way that affects
your blood glucose level at all.
Stevia can reduce blood glucose,
so in some people,
because the sweet taste,
they actually release insulin in
response to Israeli.
Can you grab a couple of those gems and
then bit thirsty,
but the downside is that if you have
somebody that has kind of an insulin
roller coaster can actually make that
problem worse.
So the Stevie is super good.
I think it's a lot better than most
artificial sweeteners,
but there are folks that can kind of get
themselves into a bad spot with it.
That's interesting.
I did not know.
That's a.
So is it?
Is there like a recommended daily
allowance of Stevia?
No.
Again,
this is just a really individualistic
thing,
you know,
and it's something that like if somebody
is a health coach or a doctor or
healthcare provider and they see
somebody that's struggling with
something and then they're like,
okay,
so how are you eating?
Like I'm eating low carb.
Okay.
So are you doing any,
uh,
artificial sweeteners or what have you,
and if they're doing something like this
then it could be something that is kind
of kicking them out of the,
the,
you know,
the insulin regulation that would work
better for them.
Hmm.
Now what do you think about colonics
related?
No,
no,
but because I feel like it was a thing
for awhile.
A lot of people were talking about
cleaning out their intestinal tract and
you know,
you just got to get water up there and
flush everything out and they,
people would like literally watch the
tube and go low.
I know what you're eating.
And I'm like,
what?
It always seemed odd to me.
That seems like there's generally an
exit only kind of process and so yeah.
Yeah.
It.
Unless you're trying to do certain
drugs,
right?
Right.
Certain drugs apparently are best when
you stick them up there,
but there's a girl named neuro soup,
I don't know if she's on youtube
anymore,
but she had this whole detailed story
about a dmt trip that she did was she
took dmt upper butt and went on like
some five hour journey into the
Netherworld because it goes directly
into your bloodstream from there,
right?
Yeah.
It's that base.
And so you've got a [inaudible] deal to
like with your hand that base kind of an
asshole or talking about you making that
hand signal.
But I always wondered if it was good for
you.
I'm like,
I just feel like you should leave that
area.
Like flooding water up there just
doesn't seem like the smartest move.
Yeah,
it seems like just skipping a meal here
and there and just kind of letting it do
its natural business seems like a pretty
good thing.
The people that I encountered that did
clonics,
they seem to be on kind of a merry go
round with it.
And they also were into some other
really squirrely,
stopped like it,
uh,
like healing,
healing and shock rose in it.
Um,
it's just seemed like they were always
moving towards something and never
really getting there and so it just
seemed odd,
like there was never like a resolution
to the situation and I kind of like
having some endpoints and then move on
and do something else.
I always get very curious of something
or very sort of,
I guess skeptical is the right word,
but have something that doesn't have any
research behind it.
So that's why I wanted to know like how
much research is there behind Kalanick
because I don't,
I never hear about any.
I've never dug into it.
So I honestly don't know.
I do know that there have been some
studies looking at the gut microbiome,
like when they do a,
uh,
a colonoscopy,
so they'll,
they'll kind of flush it out and they'll
give you some stuff to move everything
out.
And there is some research that suggests
that's not great for the gut micro or
for the,
the lower gut microbiome that there's
actually some pathological changes from
that.
So going in and getting a colonoscopy
and all of the like strafed bombing that
they do to move everything out may not
be that great.
It's a great way to put it.
Brave thinking about fighter plane.
Totally.
Agent Orange.
Um,
well I know that people that have
antibiotics that like people that are
battering battling staph infection have
a horrendous time sort of reconstructing
their gut biome.
And Rhonda Patrick detailed that on one
of the podcasts that we did,
she had a tremendous,
a staph infection and it route it
wouldn't go away.
And she actually wound up one of the
things that really helped.
It was a topical application of garlic.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Which is really interesting.
Yeah.
A garlic Oregano.
There's a lot of these traditional oil
Oregano oil and like the Oregano oil and
the garlic are really potent in general.
They kind of spare the healthy bacteria
are what we would call the more
beneficial bacteria,
but even that's not a universal story.
Like it can suppress some of the more
beneficial bacteria in some situations.
So again,
this is where if you think you've got
something going on,
it's probably smart to work with
somebody that knows a little bit about
what they're doing so that you've got a
protocol,
you can test it,
see what the results are,
and then we can make some decisions
based off that because you could really,
you know,
if you're already in a compromised state
and then you throw something like that
in,
you can end up worse.
Now,
for people that are listening,
who would someone go to,
like say if you really wanted to get
your gut biome checked out?
I mean,
someone like Chris Kresser,
uh,
there's a gal in Austin,
Amy Myers,
there's a Dr Ruscio up in the bay area.
Chris Kresser also has a,
uh,
the Kresser Institute or re certifying
healthcare practitioners.
These are the folks that you want to
check out.
Also,
the Institute of Functional Medicine is
a really good place.
Most of the doctors and healthcare
providers that go through that
functional medicine training are really
well versed in looking at the,
uh,
this whole gut microbiome story.
But he,
interestingly,
they kind of pull it back and they've
got this kind of evolutionary biology
picture that they look at,
so they're thinking about sleep and your
food and stress levels,
social connectivity,
and they really put all that stuff
together in a pretty good way and
they're not chasing symptoms are really
trying to figure out root cause and then
try to address that root cause and move
forward and they're pretty.
They're pretty good at figuring out like
you've got 18 things going,
which,
which is the one thing we need to
address first and then we'll knock that
out and go to the next one and the next
one.
And now when they start applying,
say like probiotics are,
there are all probiotics are created
equal in terms of like foods,
not in terms of like supplementation,
because I know there's some really
intense a probiotic supplements you can
buy that you have to keep refrigerated
right now.
Again,
there's huge variability in that.
You have some people that when they add
probiotics,
like just like Kimchi or Sauerkraut,
improve immediately liked their clinical
symptoms improved.
They feel better,
maybe depressive symptoms improve.
They get leaner and then you have other
people that everything they have going
on get to worse,
and these are the folks that you start
wondering if they have some small
intestinal bacterial overgrowth.
Do they add some reactivity?
There's these things called fodmaps are
fermentable carbohydrates that can,
you know,
make the gut microbiome kind of freak
out and there's another layer to this
which is called small intestinal fungal
overgrowth.
So there are people out there that have
some sort of a persistent fungal
infection which doesn't get picked up
and the general gut microbiome screening
because they're looking at bacteria and
fungus.
So this is a whole other layer to the
story that people may have had a year's
long decades long fungal infection in
the gut that is then disordering
everything causing inflammation and
those are really,
really difficult to deal with.
What does one do when they have a fungal
overgrowth?
You can do some of the antifungals like
Diflucan and and again some of the
herbal preparations,
but this is another layer,
you know,
kind of peeling the onion that there
aren't that many practitioners that are
even looking for that as an option and
then the treatment protocols are not
super well edited out.
So there's a lot of experimentation that
happens there.
Do they know what?
Is there a dietary cause?
I mean there's always an influence on
the diet,
but you know,
you could,
you know,
refined carbohydrates makes all this
stuff grow better and it disrupts the
normal gut flora.
It causes inflammation,
but you know,
oftentimes people will go on a round of
antibiotics.
The bacterial population gets pushed
down and then the fungal population,
which is always there,
but usually it's in some sort of a
symbiotic balance with the other
microbes than the,
the fungal infection or fungal
population can increase.
And this is where some people will go on
a round of antibiotics and then they end
up with some sort of a legitimate fungal
infection.
You know,
like they can see it on their skin and
the doctor will prescribe some
antifungals for that,
but you can also have this happening
kind of a low grade sub acute level
where it's not bad enough where they're
getting rashes and hives,
but it's bad enough that it's making
them sick and not kind of optimized.
Wow.
It's just so hard to figure out what's
going on with you unless you.
I mean it seems like for the average
person that has a full time job and
family and all that jazz,
it's probably incredibly difficult to
get to the bottom of what your health
issue is.
It definitely can be,
you know,
the average time for diagnosis of an
autoimmune condition or something like
celiac disease is like 12 to 15 years,
so people are suffering.
They're suffering for a long time and
it's not the easiest thing in the world
to pin down because the symptoms are so
variable from person to person.
Now if you go to a good doc,
particularly someone,
again kind of functional medicine
training or they've got a little bit of
this evolutionary biology perspective,
they usually ask a set of questions and
more questions so that they can kind of
narrow down what's going on,
but if you're kind of doing the doc in
the box deal and you've got five minutes
with this person,
like they're just trying to figure out
what's the script I'm going to write so
I can move this person out and get to
the next person.
Yeah,
that's unfortunate and you're just not
going to.
Unless you get lucky,
you're not going to figure out what the
issue is.
Yeah.
It would seem that the amount of time
required to figure out what's wrong with
the person would also be very expensive
and likely not covered by a whole lot of
healthcare plans.
Yeah,
I mean it's interesting like some of
these functional medicine docs do a lot
with pretty little,
you know,
but some of what they're doing is a time
investment.
Like they'll do a two hour history and
the.
If they can get the information the
last.
So you know,
what was your in utero environment like,
like did your mom meet?
Well,
did they smoke when you were born?
Was it a vaginal birth or csection?
Were you breastfed or not?
When was your,
uh,
the approximate age of your first round
of antibiotics?
Did you ever go on tetracycline for
extended period of time for acne?
And so they'll build a really
comprehensive early life history and
then try to March this thing forward in
the last few questions,
like did you ever travel out of country?
Did you get some sort of a gut bug while
doing that?
So there are some really important
pieces but a well trained a practitioner
will rely a lot on the intake and then
that will kind of inform where they go
with the testing.
And so the testing might be a little bit
expensive but you're not just casting
around blindly.
Like because of that really thorough
intake and kind of understanding the
early life history and trying to fair it
out.
If there's ever been like a big event
that could be linked back to this health
crisis,
then they can really dial in the
testing.
Then depending on what they get from
that,
they can make a treatment protocol.
Try the treatment protocol.
If we have success,
then good to go.
If not,
then we start modifying from there.
When you say eating foods out of the
country and catching some sort of a
bacterial infection out of that,
that is one of the scariest things in
the world to me because I've watched
that stupid show too many times.
Right.
What are the enemy within or something
like that.
Yeah.
It's hard to think of your body as being
like not just an organism but a whole
ecosystem.
Right.
And,
and stuff can come in and take up
residence in new.
Didn't really want it.
Yeah.
I had grd at twice.
Oh really?
And it's um,
it's bad.
It's bad news that uh,
the first time I snorkeling and Mexico.
Oh Jesus.
And so everybody in the main snorkeling
group was kind of out in the salt water
and then there was nobody over in this
other area.
And so I was like,
I'll swim over here.
But apparently there was a,
it was an estuary,
like there was a salt water,
fresh water interface.
And so I started swimming in the fresh
water and then they were like,
yeah,
you're really not supposed to swim in
there because this water out of a c no
tay.
And like sometimes what's the c note to
the,
uh,
the underground.
I'm kind of fresh water springs that
come out of a limestone.
I interrupted you when you were saying
people take Thompson out water dumping
the water.
Yeah.
Oh boy.
Yeah,
yeah.
I know you get the Rda from beaver poop.
That is another place.
Yeah.
And I don't know that there are beaver
in the Yucatan,
but there's some other carriers in
Prince of Wales island once about a year
and a half ago,
two years ago,
and it's really high up and it's above
the line where beavers are.
And so you could take a water bottle and
dip it into a lake and just drink it out
of the lake and you feel it's so
dangerous feeling,
but they assured us they like,
you can absolutely drink right out of
that lake.
Oh Man.
That gives me a little gut rumblings
even thinking about it.
And we had a float plane land on that
very lake.
And I'm like,
what are the things leaking in the leg?
I'm drinking diesel water.
And they're like,
there's millions of gallons of water.
And it's like,
whatever.
This is not going to affect you.
I'm like,
it says it says you.
What if I scoop it right where the thing
dropped off?
It's diesel fuel.
I don't know,
but it just seems weird that you can do
that.
And then it seems even weirder when you
think about the fact that you can't do
that everywhere that most.
Even though we're a giant percentage of
us as water really can't drink most
water rate.
My professor Loren Cordain,
the guy who kind of founded this Paleo
Diet concept,
he used to be a lifeguard at Lake Tahoe,
you know,
30 years ago,
35 years ago,
and they would jump off the pier,
dive down where it was super deep,
really cold,
open up their water bottle,
fill it up,
swing back up,
drink it,
and you can't do it now because the lake
has ge already in it and a bunch of
other weird things that happened.
Well for him,
nothing,
nothing would happen to the lake.
More people moving in and just,
you know,
it's just kind of a volume of poor input
at some point.
Kind of overwhelms the natural.
We suck.
We fucking ruined everything.
Damn people.
I mean,
most,
most indigenous cultures were savvy to
the idea that you didn't take a dump and
your own water systems.
So yeah.
Well they knew about parasites for sure.
I mean that was always a whole idea
about not eating pigs.
All the religious.
Excuse me,
all the religious rules about not eating
pigs was a big part of it was because
pigs eat almost everything.
Right?
Everything that's on the ground and they
would eat something that has chicken
gnosis in it.
People would get really,
really sick from eating pigs.
So they had sort of determined that pigs
were evil,
right in shellfish.
Similar.
Good friend of mine,
John Durant did a book called the Paleo
Manifesto and he actually has a really
interesting background,
has kind of a pretty deep kind of
religious studies
background and he would talk about some
of these food prohibitions in different
religions and then what we know about it
today.
And so things like shellfish.
You ever once while we get something
like red tide or you know,
the diatom overgrowth and these are
filter feeders would pull all this stuff
in and then get loaded up with a toxin
and it would kill you if you ate it.
And so these food prohibitions really
had some pretty good wisdom to them in
general.
But then there's also super goofy
things,
but it's pretty common across all
cultures.
Like people would,
you know,
kind of build into their systems,
these prohibitions against different
foods.
And oftentimes because of this,
uh,
kind of bacterial or,
or a parasitic deal,
I wonder what,
like the kosher ones for like and meat,
milk and meat together.
You can't have milk meet together.
I wonder what that's about.
I would have to ask him about that.
I,
I never heard anything about that.
And then it's interesting in Islam than
there's not that prohibition.
So.
And I don't know if that was just kind
of like a fuck you to the Judeo
Christian deal or what?
Yeah.
Now what about eating fats with complex
carbohydrates or fats with sugars?
Um,
does that affect your,
your glucose levels like,
and how it's absorbed by the body?
Yes.
But again,
like from person to person,
it really varies a lot.
So for some people,
you know,
if you did something like a white potato
and you're going to have a certain blood
glucose response from it and you put a
good whack of butter or olive oil or
something in it,
for one group of people,
it would actually reduce or spread out
the total glucose load.
So your blood sugar wouldn't go is high.
Your total insulin load would be lesser
as a consequence and then there are
other groups of folks that they will see
an increase in blood glucose response
and a really pronounced increase in
insulin response and is the the amount
of fats that are in like the olive oil
and the butter that's in the potato is a
uniform or they're measuring it very
carefully to the studies that had been
done.
They're quite uniform.
Yeah,
like to get in and do a pretty good job,
so they're,
you know,
person needs x amount of carbohydrate,
they add x amount of fat there kind of
standardized for body weight so that
you're diluting the glucose about the
same amount from person to person.
And so the.
The best understanding that I've seen
out of this is just that there's a
pretty good variability from person to
person as to how they're gonna respond
to that.
So it's not always a case where adding
fat to a decently dense carbohydrate
source is going to buy you anything.
For some people it is an improvement and
for other people it's actually more of a
problem.
So you'd almost have to do like kind of
experienced the experiments that you're
doing with your wife,
where you take the blood levels post,
what are you doing,
like what time periods.
So you do it for the recommendation and
it's called the seven day Carb,
tested you 50 grams of carbs and that's
the net carb.
So all the fiber subtracted out and so
if you're doing something like black
beans,
it's a huge pile of beans because have a
lot of protein and fiber.
So those things are hard to do.
Something white rice,
White Rice or you know like gluten free
bread or something would be a lot easier
to do,
but you consume that.
You set your timer for when you're done
with the meal.
Two hours later you check your blood
glucose and for my methods I'd like to
see that two hour mark probably under
150 milligrams per deciliter for folks,
which is pretty conservative.
But when we look at again,
some a pre agricultural people,
they tend to have some really,
Really Nice Blood Glucose responses.
And again,
from this weitzman paper,
what we saw from that is if people
control their blood glucose effectively,
over time the inflammation drops,
their gut microbiome improves.
And so you could have two people that
have a very different response to say
like rice or potatoes or something.
And one person like my wife,
it's kind of crazy.
Like she can just crush this stuff and
she does great.
And interestingly she can eat a
ketogenic diet and do great.
Like she just Kinda,
she can switch whatever fuels she wants
to,
she does fine with that.
But if we keep that Gut microbiome or
the blood glucose response pretty
consistently good than even someone like
me that kind of like pulled the genetic
short card in the lottery.
Like I don't,
I don't know exactly what is wrong with
me,
but I don't handle carbs that well.
Um,
if I eat in a way that my blood glucose
response looks like my wife,
that my blood lipids look good and my
gut is healthier.
Like everything else pulls into a good
spot.
So even if you're not,
um,
you know,
from that genetically talented side of
things,
if you can make your blood glucose
response look like that genetically
talented person,
then you should get most of the
metabolic benefits.
You don't have as much latitude in your
day to day eating.
But I mean,
you,
you know,
not everybody can flatfoot dunk a
basketball or something,
so you just have to take what you get.
Yeah.
That's interesting.
So you just have to kind of figure out
what it is that your body requires.
And the main goal is staying inside
these parameters.
Right?
Right.
And you know,
it's,
it's a tough thing for someone like me.
You like I love the Paleo Diet,
I love that basic concept and I don't.
In general,
if you throw out the following,
would you say most people should eat
whole unprocessed foods?
Not a lot of contention there,
you know,
but when you get a little bit granular
with that whole unprocessed foods,
could be beans,
it could be potatoes,
sweet potatoes.
And for me it's interesting like
lentils,
I do great width,
I can do a lot of lentils,
do a decent amount of carbohydrate from
lentils.
My Blood Glucose response is great if I
do rice,
white potatoes,
sweet potatoes are better.
But you know,
the rice and white potatoes,
I looked like a diabetic after eating
that stuff.
So,
um,
you know,
even though that general recommendation
of eat whole unprocessed foods is
generally spot on,
there's still a lot of details and
granularity in that,
you know,
you could be following a whole food diet
and for you,
because of your genetics or epigenetics,
like your gut or maybe taking
antibiotics in the past,
you still may need to be really careful
about the amounts and types of
carbohydrates that you eat.
That's crazy.
Taking antibiotics in the past can
affect you that far in the future.
Like how,
how much of an effect like time wise.
So there's two levels to this in my
opinion.
The one level is the gut microbiome.
There's another level to it.
Certain antibiotics,
the way that they work,
they interrupt the transcription and in
activity of the ribosomes in bacteria.
But our mitochondria are effectively a
bacteria,
like they have bacterial DNA in
ribosomes and even though in general,
like mainstream medicine says that
antibiotics don't effect mitochondrial
function.
There's some pretty good papers that
suggest that antibiotics can disrupt and
damage mitochondrial function.
And when your Mitochondria gets sick,
you die.
Like this is so much of what Rhonda
Patrick Talks about with,
you know,
the benefits of fasting and having
really good micro nutrient density and
whatnot.
And you know what Tim Ferriss pinged me
a question about why is lyme disease has
gotten so much worse for people,
you know,
use to.
It was kind of like catching a cold,
you know,
a lived in upstate New York.
Everybody seemed to get it.
It wasn't something that would cripple
people over the long haul.
And now you're seeing a lot of longterm
problems.
But my question was,
is it really the lyme disease or is it
the damage to the Mitochondria from
being on antibiotics longterm?
Because the lyme disease requires a
really long treatment protocol with
antibiotics.
That's fascinating.
But isn't it even worse for people that
go misdiagnosed?
And so they don't get on the antibiotics
for a long time and the lyme disease
gets deep,
deep,
deep into their system.
Yeah.
I honestly,
I don't know much on that side.
I've been looking so much at this kind
of mitochondrial dysfunction side.
I can't really comment much on like the
longterm untreated lyme disease.
Lyme disease is a scary thing because
there's so many ticks that have it now.
I was talking to some people this
weekend and they were like,
yeah,
my mom's got it.
My Dad's got it.
I got it.
You know,
how many Goddamn people are getting lit
up by these ticks and catching this
little freaky disease.
And where was it 20,
30 years ago,
you know,
it's funny.
Npr just had a piece on this and it was,
uh,
some of the modern farming practices has
killed off the predators that would
normally knock the tick population down.
Like what I,
I forget,
you know,
I,
I literally just kind of scanned it,
but uh,
somebody that commented on,
they're like,
oh yeah,
this is why we have free range chickens
on her property to basically keep the
tick population down.
But part of what is suppressing that is
that the free range chickens are eating
mice and stuff.
So the mice are a vector that allows the
ticks to,
to grow and populate.
So the,
you know,
I just scanned this thing,
but it was,
it was interesting,
but it was suggesting that the kind of
mono cropping process of what we've done
with modern agriculture has created this
gap where we now have pes like Mammalian
pest,
like mice and moles that
are a vector for the ticks.
And so they've just got more surface
area,
more more uh,
uh,
real estate that they can live on.
And so their population has grown.
That's a really important factor for
people that don't like coyotes.
Like there's a lot of people that are
very angry that coyote coyote ate my
dog.
Like I understand.
And it is terrible.
However,
the coyote,
he also eats every rat,
right?
You can find,
and that's one of the reasons why rats
aren't everywhere.
And if you go to New York City,
you see very few coyotes and I'll fuck
load of rats.
And what would you rather have?
I think I'd rather have a few coyotes
every now and then the occasional loss
cat then fucking black plague running
through your neighborhood in the
suburbs.
It's true.
But uh,
they have eaten three of my cats in
Reno,
so I do smoke a lot.
How do you get them archery or with a
suppressed rifle?
Awhile.
Doors.
Do you know that when you kill coyotes
you actually increased the population?
Yeah.
It's no head off and yeah,
I,
I know,
but that's the reason why there's
coyotes in every single state.
And we have a podcast coming up with a
guy named Dan Flores who,
uh,
wrote a book called Coyote America that
I read.
It's fucking amazing.
But coyotes,
when they yell out what they're doing,
all that stuff is,
they're doing roll call and they all
chime in.
And when one is missing,
it triggers a response in the female to
produce more cubs.
Interesting.
So in healthy conditions,
when they're not being pressured,
the female will produce like three or
few cups.
When they are being pressured,
they'll produce like a dozen or more.
It's crazy lake and spread out to change
their area.
Humans will be long gone and coyotes and
cockroaches will still be here.
They will inherit the earth.
Yeah.
Well,
it's also amazing how many native
American myths and stories evolved,
uh,
about the coyote and about how the
coyote was this sort of God that was
kind of watching over everything and was
responsible for creation and a lot of
other things like really weird,
freaky smart little animal is a wolf
too,
by the way.
Yeah.
So I,
I had read some stuff about the Coi wolf
where the wolf populations had been
really pushed back and so they started
crossbreeding with coyotes.
And so now we're coyotes were maybe
about like 25,
30 pounds now there'll be 70 or 80
pounds and they hunt in packs.
And so they've got these characteristics
of wolves and coyotes.
And quite a few of them,
but one of the things that's important
is that coyotes,
when a coyote and wolf breed,
they're basically the same animal.
So even though there's variations in the
way they behave,
particularly in that,
coyotes can hunt alone and they can hunt
in packs.
Whereas Wolf's almost exclusively hunt
Right?
The,
um,
they shared DNA.
So the,
when they have babies,
they're viable.
Right.
So it's not like a hybrid.
They're basically the same animal.
It's really weird.
Yeah.
They're everywhere.
They're apparently they're having a real
issue with them in New York City.
You have them in central park.
They have them in Queens.
Yeah.
The urban areas are some of the most
vibrant locations for the coyotes.
Yeah.
And I mean they just crush like,
uh,
the,
the pet population.
Like you love your pets out at night.
Like you're,
it's Russian roulette with that.
It is,
it's even though the day man,
I have chickens and I had one chicken,
one of my chickens got stolen by a
coyote and I watched him hop the fence
with it in his mouth and I was like,
wow.
It turned out her mouth.
It turned out she was a female and she
had cubs.
Oh Wow.
Yeah.
And I was trying to figure out what to
do.
I just kind of let it alone.
I was going to kill her.
I was going to figure out a way to kill
her,
but then I thought,
well if I kill her then the like part of
it,
I don't want the babies grow up and kill
my chickens more.
But then the other thing is I don't want
to stop a mother from feeding.
Right.
I felt like I fucked up.
Like I didn't secure the yard enough.
It was my fault and there's a game being
played in the game is stay alive and the
chickens are playing away.
Easier version of stay alive and the
coyote is.
So I felt like I had to give her that
point.
Right.
All right.
You got that one on the board.
Don't eat my fucking dog.
I will.
I'll kill you.
All right.
You know,
that's,
that's where it crosses the line.
Like my,
my appreciation,
love for my chickens is,
is a 1000th of my cat.
You know what I mean?
Right.
So it's different.
Yeah.
Well my wife convinced me to get a
Rhodesian ridgeback.
Oh,
those are the dog and he's a great dog.
He's about 105 pounds and two percent
body fat and I wouldn't want them
getting mixed up in a pack of coyotes,
but I think he could probably hold his
own for a good bit if,
if something went down sneaky though,
one of them will come out and they'll
like taunt them.
Right.
And then they'll chase them and then the
other ones we'll ambush or like if the
female lou the coyote is is a fertile at
that point and either pumping out the
pheromones in the lure or the dog away
and they're like,
yeah,
you didn't get any action and we're
gonna eat you a great story that this
guy told me who worked at my pet food
store and he also works as a nurse in a
veterinary office and they brought this
pit bull and it was one of those freak
pitbulls that people breed and get it to
like 120 pounds.
Have you ever seen those?
There's A.
There's a company called land of the
giants and I think they're in
Massachusetts and they make these pit
bulls that look like bodybuilders.
They don't even look real.
Anyway,
this guy had a pit bull like that and
they brought it into the vet's office
and it was just covered in massive cuts.
It required something in the range of a
thousand plus stitches all over its
body.
And they're like,
what happened?
He goes,
I don't know.
That dog got out of the yard.
And he's just just covered insurance.
They figured maybe it was a dog fight or
something they didn't know,
but there was just a trail of blood that
lead from his house up into the hills
where he found nine dead.
Coyotes smokes.
Yeah.
So they just laid a trap for him and he
just fucked him all up like a huge
mistake.
And he brought this freak,
this brock Lesnar pit bull into our
midst.
And he just mauled in.
The whole family is gone now.
Everyone's dead.
He killed them all.
He tore them apart,
like in apparently they just kept
fighting.
I don't,
I don't know what happened,
but he said it was spread out,
you know,
the carnage was spread out over several
yards.
But,
uh,
this pit bull,
just what town?
Pimples or pop.
I mean,
they're just amazing animals.
they are incredibly strong.
That jaw power is just off the hook.
They're really smart.
So yeah,
they're a.
That would be a handful,
especially if it's like 130 pounds.
And Jack,
the thing about the pit bull is that
it's not worried about dying the way of
coyotes.
Coyotes,
because no one's feeding them,
their whole thing is like stay alive,
survive,
you know,
attack and kill something,
but don't fight to the death.
Right.
Whereas a pit bull is essentially bred
to fight to the death and the ones that
didn't,
they were removed from the breeding
population,
like the horrible truth of pit bull
fighting is like that.
Michael Vick story were the ones that
would quit or the ones that would turn
that wouldn't,
wouldn't engage in the fight.
They would kill them in torture comes
horrible,
horrible stuff.
But because of that really nasty,
cruel,
vicious way of approaching the dog
breeding,
what they get is this bloodline of for
warriors that just have no fear of death
and when you get one,
it's 120 pounds like that.
Like fuck man.
Right,
right.
What a giant mistake.
I don't know if it 120 pounds,
I might be making that number up is
huge.
Huge pit bull.
I think they way they're supposed to run
like 60 pounds I think at the upper end.
So when you start doubling that,
that's a real fighter ones are 35
pounds.
Okay.
And when they fight them,
they're small,
right?
Like when people have this idea of a pit
bull in their eyes,
they have this idea of a guard dog,
but it's not really the ones that they
fight.
They're really not that big,
but their physical muscles aren't that
big because really it's all about having
the endurance and having the gameness to
attack and killed,
pull up this website,
land of the giants,
land of the giants pit bulls.
Because like a friend of my senate to me
almost like,
what the fuck is this?
Like they've just figured out a way to
do the same thing that the poultry
industry has done,
just breed bigger and bigger chickens
until you have this fried chicken and
can barely walk.
Right.
These guys have done that with pitbulls
where it's just like,
it looks like they're breeding it with
something else,
but it's really just maybe some Amazon,
the puppy chow or something that would
that work.
I wonder if people have done that,
like,
like inject steroids and guarantee
somebody's done that.
Yeah,
sure.
Right.
Yeah,
yeah.
Pitbulls,
uh,
have an incredible bite,
but what's really crazy is that a wolf
is a bite that's five times stronger
than a pit bull.
Really?
Yeah.
Both has a bite that's,
I think it's 2,500
pounds per square inch versus 500 for
the,
for the pit bull.
Look at that thing isn't quite the same
one,
but there's their bigs were giants and
that size of these things.
That is so ridiculous.
A lot of dog that it's such a ridiculous
dog.
Did you see that land of the giants
website?
Did
you find it?
I typed it in and just like a facebook
page popped up.
Oh really?
I wonder forums asking about them,
but they might've went under.
I don't know.
Who knows?
Yeah,
it's really crazy that all these years
dogs,
whether it's a Chihuahua or an English
bulldog,
all of them came from wolves.
My,
a four year old daughter asked me about
that.
She was like,
dad had were all dogs from wolves and
I'm like,
yeah.
And she's like,
how does that work?
And like I'm trying to explain genetics
and genetic variability and everything
and it was uh,
it's um,
if you could explain something to a kid
then you've got a pretty good grasp on
it.
But I think that she kinda Kinda got the
gist of it.
The way I tried to explain it to someone
was that it's kind of like people
because people,
you know,
you have like bridge damages and then
you get Shaquille o'neal,
they're both people,
right.
But one of them obviously is a genetic
disorder,
but you could sort of breed for that
genetic disorder.
Right.
And will the guy like Shaquille o'neal,
me and Shaquille o'neal or in the same
species,
like how's that even possible,
you know,
like they look so different.
Right.
And that sort of like dogs that we by
preference and breeding and you know,
and I guess geography as well,
that's a huge factor as well.
But.
Right.
But it is interesting like that.
The Wolf coyotes,
I guess like Dingoes,
like there's a real uniformity there.
Like nature ended up pushing some things
where they've got this kind of Snotty
Nis and they've got good hearing,
a good smell,
but not like a hound dog,
which has better smell,
you know,
it's,
it.
It's interesting.
And there's also an interesting genetic
variability in terms of what kind of
temperature their,
their body has to be involved.
Like for,
um,
certain mammals,
when they grow farther north,
they become much,
much larger,
right?
Like white tailed deer in like Alberta
can get to around 300 pounds.
Whereas in Texas they're only like 100
pounds.
Maybe 1:50
is like a big deer,
you know,
it's,
it's fascinating that their body just
decides that,
look,
the way,
the best way to stay warm is to be
enormous,
right?
It's more round and shorter limbs.
Sure.
Stuff was like polar bears are some of
the largest bears or Kodiak Alaska
bears,
which is sort of a perfect example
because in Kodiak island,
those brown bears have access to massive
amounts of protein and salmon and
beached whales and deer and bonds and
things like that because they're just
such a genetic.
Uh,
there's such a genetically powerful
creature as is a brown bear,
but then give them all this massive
amounts of protein and incredible food.
And then on top of that it's freezing
fucking cold.
So they just become these enormous
behemoths.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
That's
came out about dinosaurs today.
You were just talking about the
dinosaurs are real,
bro.
Did you watch that podcast?
It's not about that.
It's a,
that some.
Sorry,
some scientists did a bunch of research.
He did like three years of research on
himself or on his own.
He said he went into museums and
studying the bone fragments and uh,
he put all of his information into a
computer program and after five minutes
it spit out something that said that,
like all of the,
uh,
are the two major like dinosaur family,
trees are different side of this little
sun was up here is like what you
thought.
I said this is something like telling
you that either cats or dogs or what you
thought they were.
And some of the animals you call cats
are actually dogs.
This is what I discovered.
Oh,
that is sort of like,
like,
it's like that.
Oh,
okay.
So for a dummy like me that doesn't know
much about dinosaurs,
theropods to all of them,
the classic tree.
Interesting.
So what is it,
what are they saying though?
What,
um,
were there from might be diff,
like they stopped,
this particular kind came from South
America before and now it might have
come from Norway.
Dinosaurs came from New Orleans.
Yeah.
That's why one of the things that stay
saying,
so like this is one guy and at this news
hit the waves today.
It's like making big headlines all over
about like what does this information
mean?
And uh,
I was just thinking as you guys were
saying that about wolves,
that like what if they find out next
week that all doug didn't come from a
snake bite from cats or some shit like
that.
Wow.
How strange.
Yeah,
it's super strange and their diets are a
little different.
They had some real small ones,
had different kinds of teeth that proved
that they were omnivores and not
necessarily like carnivores are
herbivores or whatever.
That's a good lesson in like all science
should have a sign hung on it that says
good until further notice and you don't
like turn it into religious doctrine and
assume that it's 100 percent factual.
You know,
we create models and hopefully those
models help us kind of predict and model
the world.
But you know,
when you get better,
newer information,
you may have to scuttle that whole
thing.
Yeah.
There was an article that I tweeted and
then a followup article earlier today or
last night rather about a scientific
journals about some scandals that are
emerging from scientific journals or
scientific journals are essentially
operating on a pay to play basis.
Some of them,
they're publishing these things without
really vetting the information that's
inside the papers and ces.
It just seems like anytime money gets
involved and stuff,
people become assholes.
Sting,
operation reveal sciences,
insane.
Fake news problem.
I love the term fake news,
right?
Just such an anti intellectual.
It's so anti intellectual,
you know,
like fake news.
It's fake.
Like when Donald Trump says that you are
fake news,
like,
like how are you allow that?
Like there should be a like a list of
things that would disqualify you from
being the president.
Like as soon as you say that you're
okay.
Did you say that?
Yeah.
Okay.
You got it.
You got to step down,
right?
Can't.
You can't call CNN fake news.
Yeah.
You are fake news.
No,
they are the news.
You might think they're biased.
You make thing that you might be able to
point out some inaccuracies and make
them make print a retraction,
but yet calling them fake news like
that.
Just that term that anyone can use and
it's such a small mouth noise to make
news fake news and you say next.
Yeah,
next like Whoa,
buddy settled.
You're fucking with the entire process
that the district,
because of your own power and the
inconvenience of someone telling you
challenging things,
you're fucking with the entire process
of getting information to people.
Right?
Like this.
This last election cycle was really
interesting.
Like is it a man?
I don't know.
Like it would be.
I think kind of cool to be 50 years down
the road and look back at how all this
plays out.
I don't know that it's going to be great
living through it.
Like I have these thoughts that there's
going to be like the Great North
American States at some point,
whether the,
the s has like five different sub
countries after some horrific thing goes
down,
but it people are so entrenched in the
radiology and it's just,
it's virtually impossible to get
somebody on the opposite side of a
fence.
Avid discussion about anything in any
meeting of the minds.
And uh,
it's interesting to me.
I really think social media is kind of
facilitated this historical yet like
print paper for,
you know,
maybe a couple of hundred years and
people would have,
you know,
a community gatherings and they would
talk about different topics.
But that meeting in person and the
potential of pissing somebody off and
having them like try to beat you to
death or vice versa.
There is a certain civility that occurs
with that.
And within social media you get those
same deep held beliefs.
But then you don't have the ramification
of somebody wanting to kick the shit out
of you if you start upping the ante on
something.
And so like the,
the discourse is just crazy,
like there's just no discussion.
There's no middle ground,
there's no understanding in this.
Let's last election cycle was really
crazy and like it kind of broke me in
some ways.
Like I,
I,
uh,
am way less inclined to invest in much
of anything now.
Whereas before I would kind of bleed a
little bit for some social causes and
trying to,
to put some thoughts out about
something.
But it was just kinda like,
fuck it,
I just don't care anymore.
Well there are a lot of people that
invest tremendous amount of time,
a tremendous amount of time just
engaging with people and fighting and
arguing and insulting and attacking
people online.
And I have gone to a bunch of different
twitter pages where I go,
how many hours is this guy on?
And then I check to see like when does
he start his tweets?
And then there's people that are
tweeting 12 hours a day.
Right?
And it's all mean nasty attack shit.
Like some mentally ill person has a
computer and nothing is preventing them
from just going after people and
trolling people and attacking people.
What disturbs me is not just that,
but also this natural human tendency
that we seem to have where you have an
idea in your head and then that idea is
not just an idea,
but it's your idea and you have to
defend that idea even if it's a
preposterous idea,
like the earth is flat.
Right,
and what you find out is that these
people form groups and other people who
have also sort of adopted this
preposterous idea and refuse to look at
all at any evidence at pointed.
That's
a silly idea and instead they dig their
heels in and get confirmation bias from
all these other people.
And then they formed these social media
groups,
facebook groups.
They go to websites,
they get on web forums and they start
interacting with each other and
exclusively interacted with each other.
And then also in forcing each other's
beliefs and,
and great job,
man.
Good job of attacking those shells.
Right?
You know those.
Like if you.
Do you know if you think the earth is
round,
you are at globe hard.
That's the newest.
Jamie literally like cringed each took
them.
He had.
I had to like step back.
Blink his eyes.
Yeah.
You're a globe toward that.
That whole thing is because these
people,
someone said something that someone
went,
well,
people love to find the secrets they
love.
Like this dinosaur thing is cool because
it seems to be real and you see the gal
that said that all the fossils were
basically people doing like kind of
Michelangelo deal and Chiseling the
matter rock because the fossils came out
of rock.
Oh you got you.
And she actually what?
She hasn't pretty nice boobs too.
But yeah,
maybe that's why people are listening,
but just like,
I've got a platform now you've got tits.
It's really good.
I mean,
so she's basically like,
okay,
so these things come out of rocks.
So these anthropologists,
because there's millions of dollars in
anthropology or archeology there,
just chiseling these bones out of rock
and here we go to her
fossils that are found in the ground.
What's that?
You don't want to play games against
dinosaurs.
I wouldn't need to play some of us.
Okay.
I'm a little bit about the composition
composition,
what they end up being when everything
is said and done.
So,
uh,
fossil fossil piece of bone.
So is actually a bone that was once in
the ground that has been then filled
with limestone,
calcium and other kinds of stone link
deposits over the course of many,
many years left eyes out a patch of the
day that ends up looking like,
why is she doing that glass?
What's your fucking hair out this big?
And you say,
okay,
there's a bunch of fossils go.
Okay,
can you hand the rock off?
Paleontologist paleontologist takes a
little malate and they chip away at it
and at some point they come out with
something looking like a bomb and this
is a problem.
Hold on.
This is the problem.
Just pause that.
The problem is some fucking idiot.
Like this gets to talk about a subject
that she's not educated in and no one is
over her shoulder.
Got Eh,
that's not true.
That's not true.
And here's the thing to people that,
you know,
someone out there who buys into a lot of
the stupid shit,
you must be an expert in something,
you know,
think about what you do for a living.
You know,
like this.
Here's
a perfect example.
Like some of someone tried to tell me
that,
like,
a lot of these cheat touch martial arts
guys are two deadly to fight in the UFC.
And if they make a video,
they make a video about this and I'm not
there while they're making this video.
So I can't talk to them like in stop
them and pause them and go,
nope,
that's not true.
Nope,
that's not.
that's not correct.
No,
no.
Here's actually what happens when you
get knocked out.
No,
it is not a fucking cheat discretion or
dispersion technique.
You're not really interrupting the
shockers flow.
No,
it's a fucking concussion.
Stupid.
And we can measure concussions.
We know about all the different
variables in the blood.
When you could prove it was actually.
There's some new tests that I wanted to
get into as well.
Um,
where they,
um,
there's an institute now that's checking
concussions and they're checking,
they're doing blood tests on people to
find out about concussions that they've
had in the past and how those
concussions have healed.
Obviously I'm deviating from the path,
but the point is I know a lot about
martial arts,
so if someone wants to do a video about
martial arts while I'm an actual martial
arts expert and I can talk to you about
what you're saying,
that's incorrect.
I know about the history of it.
I know what,
what works and why it works.
I know about Torque and leverage and all
these different variables,
but you could make a video with without
me being there and you could ramble on
or not even me in any martial arts
expert and you could ramble on and if
someone doesn't know,
they watched and they go,
wow,
that guy dropping some truth bombs.
Right?
This is amazing.
You know,
I don't know if you saw this,
but Matt Thornton,
he's the founder,
really brilliant guy,
and they put together this.
I forget who it was.
It's kind of a philosophy department and
they put together this kind of white
sheet on using Brazilian Jujitsu in
particular as a means of teaching
critical thinking to students because
there's this really testable,
verifiable process.
Does it work or does it not work?
And you can define what working means
versus this kind of like,
you know,
cheat,
didn't lock death touch type type stuff.
And so they've actually developed this
curriculum around using this physical
process of Brazilian Jujitsu and I think
also mixed martial arts in general,
but specifically Jujitsu as a means of
teaching critical thinking skills and
said,
I'll,
I'll noodle on what like Kinda like the
search terms for would be.
But it's really interesting and it,
it's um,
it's something that I think helps pull
this stuff together because you've got
that kinesthetic element of people being
able to feel,
okay,
you know,
somebody gets mounted onto you,
can you get them off?
No,
we'll look at this 100,
10 pound chick.
She can dismount this person conditions
using these techniques of leverage and
balance and timing and all that stuff.
And so then you can throw these things
out about is this a verifiable process,
yes or no?
And it is.
And so then you start laying the
foundation of being able to create a
good critical thinking process.
One of the things that I really love
about Brazilian Jujitsu in particular is
that it seems to be a study in variable
absolutes,
meaning that there's so many variables
involved in like two people engaging
with each other.
Say if two people are blue belts and the
engage with each other and one person
dominates that person with superior
technique and knowledge and gets the tap
over and over again.
You could take that same person who
dominated that person and then put him
in there with a guy leg Jacques Ra and
he would just get manhandled and it
would look like he knows virtually
nothing about Jujitsu because some one
person's the variables,
the understanding of all the
complexities of the techniques they have
mastered them and they have also built
their body to a much stronger physical
unit.
So all these are variables,
but the absolute is getting the arm bar,
getting the choke,
putting someone to sleep with a choke,
like those things are absolute.
It's like where you tap out if you're
not just like a person who gets scared
really quick and taps out for no reason
which does happen,
but you're thinking about someone who
has some experience.
When you're tapping out,
you're essentially saying,
you've got me into this absolute
position.
I'm,
I'm at the point of death or massive
injury.
Knees tearing apart,
arms breaking.
So in doing those,
you encounter these variable absolutes
in a way that is really kind of uncommon
in our world,
outside of fucking car accidents and
someone hitting you over the head with a
baseball bat and you,
you,
you will encounter the consequences of
actions and movements in a way that sort
of makes you really appreciate the
overall variables of life and how
important it is to take care of your
health.
How important it is to know what you're
talking about.
You know,
if,
if fighting.
I was trying to talk about fighting is
if it's a language and if one person has
like one word,
they yell at you and they're like really
good at going,
shut the fuck up.
Like one expression like that might work
with some people.
It's not gonna work with someone who's
got a really good grasp of the English
language.
Oh I should shut the fuck up and wash
it.
I shut the fuck up because you would
like that.
Why would you like that?
Because you're too stupid to have a
conversation about something you don't
know you're talking about and that
person's like,
oh,
it's really like drowning in which is
the same way you'd feel of Damien Maia
was on top of you trying to choke you.
It's a lot like a language,
like you don't have enough variables to
respond to this particular thing and
then there's also the strength factor
and those other factors.
I think it teaches you critical thinking
in a way that is almost unavailable
outside of like war and like real
physical trauma.
Because the beautiful thing about
Jujitsu is although you can get injured,
most of it is pretty safe,
right?
Compared to boxing or kickboxing.
Yeah.
You've got a much more forgivable kind
of margin of error on that.
Yeah.
Much more and I think the environment
that it establishes,
that it creates and the way that effect
that it has on your mind,
what's forcing you into these extreme
problems,
situations and solving those problems.
Then understanding where that go wrong,
what can I do to my body to maybe
strengthen myself so that I can stop
that from happening or maybe understand
the position.
So two steps ahead.
I recognize that if I go left,
I run into that and if I go right,
I run into this,
what I need to do is be patient,
use my hips,
hip escape,
do this,
do that.
And those,
those variables and understanding those
variables and having that,
that database in your mind and
recognizing that that is also,
that's there's,
there's analogies that you could make in
all sorts of avenues in life that were,
that would be greatly beneficial.
Well,
it and again,
uh,
just another hat tip to Matt Thornton,
like he's just made this point that
these,
um,
uh,
alive art,
whether it's wrestling or boxing or Thai
boxing,
Jujitsu,
judo,
um,
there's kind of an authenticity with
that because you really can't bullshit.
It's kind of like,
can you speak Spanish?
Okay,
well let's have a conversation in
Spanish reading Spanish newspaper and
tell me what was going on with it.
Can you swim?
You know,
Sam Harris,
I think he wrote that piece,
you know,
Jujitsu was like drowning for a non,
for a non swimmer,
looking at someone treading water,
it looks inconsequential and you throw
them in the water and they're going to
die.
And so there's a real authenticity there
that when you get in and do that
compared to some of the fantasy martial
arts where there is an assumption that
just going through some sort of paces is
going to get you somewhere and it
doesn't necessarily mean that it does,
you know?
And so there's this whole great feedback
loop and it crushes your ego and you
have to really stay grounded if you're
gonna maintain through that process,
but it has so much value with every
other facet of your life.
You know,
it's fascinating.
Yeah.
If you can keep from being injured,
if you.
Yeah.
And I think one of the things that
really helped to keep from being injured
is I think it's very critical to
strengthen the body and I think there's
a lot of people that don't like to do
that.
They just like to train.
And I was guilty of that for quite a
while until I just mounted up a series
of injuries that I almost couldn't deny
it anymore,
uh,
particularly back injuries,
but strengthening the body and sort of
strengthening the overall structure in
which you engage in these sorts of
things.
Meaning not just strengthening the body
will by lifting weights and doing
squats,
but also by yoga also by doing really
unusual exercise like kettlebell
windmills and stuff like that.
That really puts a very bizarre load on
the spine and weird ways.
And it's really strengthens the core in
a substantial manner that allows you to
deal with the pressure of certain
positions without succumbing to the,
you know,
the,
the attempt by your opponent.
Right.
You know,
it's a,
it's an interesting topic because you
have someone like Marcello Garcia that
he's like,
I just roll and clearly that word is
injured now.
He's,
he's definitely,
you can just roll,
right?
You definitely can do it.
And if you're as until you can't.
Yeah.
It's technical as him.
He also has weird genetics.
Like if you look at Marcello's body,
his legs look like a man who weighs 300
pounds.
I mean he has cankles slack.
Yeah.
Shannon cafs giant legs.
And that's one of the reasons why he's
so good at controlling the back is he's
using his legs and smashing you.
Huge legs.
Well let me ask you about that.
Like I've been a big fan again of kind
of this straight blast gym stuff of you
know,
like non attribute based training,
like how do you break that up?
So like if you were flexible,
are your explosive or,
or what have you.
How much of that do you rely on versus
trying to develop this stuff where
you've got a game that you could do,
whether you're 40 years old or 80 years
old,
like how do you play back and forth with
that to to,
you know,
optimize that process?
A real good question,
and I think a good study is Roy Jones Jr
and Roy Jones Jr in his prime was
probably the most attribute based
fighter of all time with substantial
attributes.
His speed and his style though the
movement in which he used inside the
ring was really very difficult for
people to handle,
but as soon as that went away,
his physical attributes sorta started to
deteriorate.
His career declined substantially.
He went from being the best in the
world.
Two years later,
people wanted him to retire and he went
from and there's a bunch of variables
that could have happened in that fact.
I think some manipulation of hormones we
know,
I'm just speculating,
but I believe steroids are probably
involved in him moving up from light
heavyweight to heavyweight or a beat
John Ruiz for the heavyweight title and
was jacked at 200 pounds shredded and
then went down and fought Antonio Tarver
and looked listless and soft and didn't
look as fast and I think a lot of that
was his body responding to the fact that
he,
his hormone levels were off.
And I don't know if he was checking that
stuff,
but I bet he probably wasn't.
I bet he just had lost too much weight
and dehydrated himself too much.
Getting down to that 175 pound limit
again.
So tarver knocked him out and then Glenn
Johnson knocked him out after the fight
and it was bad.
Right.
I think that,
um,
when Roy was in his prime though,
he did some things that were so hard to
handle,
so unconventional because of his
ridiculous speed.
Like very rarely did he throw the jab
instead,
he would throw a lead hook and we throw
a lead hook and it was as fast as a jab,
but it would knock people to fuck out,
right?
You know,
he would just,
just good leap in on your plot and you
see guys get hit and then boom,
the right hand would be behind it.
He was so fucking fast.
So when he was young,
he beat Bernard Hopkins and he beat him
pretty handily when he was older.
Bernard Hopkins beat him,
beat him pretty handily,
and Bernard Hopkins was always older
than him.
So when he was young,
Bernard Hopkins who had that very
defensive based style,
keeps his hands up very high,
very technical,
couldn't deal with the speed of Roy
Jones Jr.
He just was ridiculous.
But as soon as roy lost a step and it's
speed,
tHen his style's not really the best
style.
The best style is the most technical
And you can do that most technical style
with extreme attributes,
right?
So I would agree with them that the best
thing to learn is the proper way of
learning all the techniques like
learning good defensive posture,
good,
hands up when you're throwing strikes,
good movement and footwork and not just
relying on freak athleticism.
Think it's probably the best way to
attack it.
What do you think about the really grip
dependent games?
You know like all the,
the spider guard and all that stuff.
Like I see these guys doing really
amazing stuff but it seems like their
hands are broken and it pretty young age
and I mean maybe that's something that
you burn just to because you've got a
competitive career and then you've got
to kind of shift games.
But then you have someone like crohn who
really.
He has an interesting,
you know,
open guard game where it's a lot of
color control and stuff like that and
he's not getting in and doing like
spider garden inversions and whatnot.
And you could argue is mayBe not as
successful as a lot of other people in
that.
That really competitive circuit.
But he also seems to be motoring along
pretty well.
Reasonably injuRy free and still has a
very powerful game.
Well he is an incredibly powerful game.
You also have to think,
well his dad is the greatest jujitsu
player time,
so that had to play a factor,
although it didn't really train much
with his dad,
which is kind of unusual.
Um,
he doesn't have the,
he doesn't his dad.
And when I say the basics,
what I mean the basics,
I don't mean like it's a simple game.
His game very complex,
but he doesn't do any weird sorta della
hiva stuff or weird spider guard stuff.
Like his game is basically the same kind
of jujitsu used to see in 1994 when
hickson was the king.
But it's not it.
It's just super tuned in and high level
and razor sharp like his.
One of his best submissions is the good
team has another best submissions,
a rear naked choke.
And if he gets you in those positions,
you're foxville right.
You know,
and it's really just that his technique
is so fucking sharp and it's,
there's levels to that sharpness of
technique.
you know,
there's some guys that just have a
technique that is so god damn sharp,
it's impossible to avoid like on a level
lower level,
but there was a guy named paul sas used
to compete in the ufc who's to fucking
triangle everybody.
He wants something like nine or 10
matches by triangles.
Ridiculous.
He just would pull guard and then you'd
be fucked.
He would just figure out a way to wrap
your neck and arm around his legs,
squeeze the shit out of it.
And next thing you know you're tapping
or blacked out.
Right?
And people knew what he would do.
They knew that that was his game and
they would still get caught in a
triangle.
It's like,
what the fuck?
Right?
It's because his technique was so razor
sharp.
So I,
I think there's a lot of people that get
caught up in those grabbing a games,
those grip dependent games and maybe
they,
you know,
they would go,
well let me try it on you.
I'll fuck you up wiTh it.
And they,
maybe they would fuck me up with it.
But I honestly believed that the best
jujitsu is jujitsu that you can do with
ge or without a [inaudible].
And a lot of those guys where they get
into mma,
they don't have any handles to grab,
right?
So nogi jujitsu is much more like greco
roman wrestling,
whereas eddie bravo and his 10th planet
jiu jitsu system,
when he's done a sort of incorporate
much more,
no,
uh,
like greco roman control.
And you can do that.
Like when I,
I still roll with the gang,
but when I do [inaudible] jujitsu,
I very rarely grabbed the gay.
Right.
Everything I'm doing is like under hooks
over hooks.
I'm getting gAble grips and I'm using
nogi techniques with agi.
So for me,
what I like about the ge is defensively
I can't fuck around,
right?
Like I can't just yank out of arm bars
and shit.
Like if you're in there with a good guy
and he's got you in his garden is a key.
There's so much friction that you have
to really be careful.
But I think offensively you have to be
very careful to not use that key.
Right.
But the good thing about learning how to
use the g,
it's like say if you get in a fight with
someone and they have a winter coat on
their fucking dead,
right?
You know,
some guy wants some drunk,
wants to kick your ass and you just get
your hand inside his collar and like,
oh,
look at you,
you're a dead man,
you know,
you're dead.
Like if you get a guy who's like got a
good ezekiel choke or something like
that and he gets a hold of you and he's
on top of you.
And he gets his,
his own color and wraps around,
chokes you to death with his own arms.
You know,
it's,
uh,
that's good stuff.
Yeah.
There's,
there's like judo player,
like if someone like jimmy pedro gets a
hold of your leather jacket,
you're fucked man.
He's gonna hit you with the world
essentially.
Like when someone's throwing you in the
ground,
like a real world class,
judoka hitting you in the head with the
world,
they're going to throw you on your head,
you're going to go unconscious.
Right?
Have you guys had henry akin on?
No,
I haven't.
Henry's amazing.
Yeah.
Such a good guy.
He's a black belt under hixon as well.
Yeah,
I know henry very well.
Yeah.
He's,
you know,
hickson's black belts.
There's,
there's certain,
there's like a.
There's a few black belts like,
whoa.
You've got a henzel gracie black belt.
That's fucking legit.
Right.
There's a few of those like that in
hixson is one of the most legitimate
those.
Yeah.
Henry is just a great guy in his game is
really interesting.
Like the g and the nogi game are
virtually identical.
I mean you do a little stuff for the
color jokes and whatnot,
but otherwise it's,
it's just completely uniform from geeta
nogi and so it's,
it's interesting for me to being 45 and
trying to motor through this stuff and
I'm really not that bright of a person.
It's like I need transferable job
skills.
Like I want to learn something once and
not need a million nuances for things.
A dummies right now or listening to this
going,
you're not bright.
What am I fucking champ?
Shit.
He's not brIght.
Fuck.
Could be.
Could be now a,
what are you doing to regulate your
hormones or check your hormones?
I checked them about yearly and uh,
you know,
the main deal with that is just keeping
a really good eye on my sleep,
my nutrition recovery.
I do some hrv monitoring and the heart
rate variability,
so you check that in the morning and
basically hrv was studied,
developed,
discovered by the eastern bloc countries
and it was part of the space program and
it's looking at the total alice static
load or the stress load on an
individual.
So the heart,
if you have 60 beats a minute,
it doesn't necessarily mean that it's
beating once a second.
You may have three beats that go really
fast and then there may be a long pause
and then two beats and so there's
variability to.
And it's basically chaos mathematics
that describes this stuff,
but if you are not under significant
stress,
if your parasympathetic nervous system,
the rest and restore part is kind of
brought to the fore like breathing,
meditation,
yoga,
that sort of stuff.
Then you tended to have more heart rate
variability and that's a good thing.
when you get under stress,
then you tend to have less heart rate
variability and becomes more metronomic,
so I've found that if I keep an eye on
my heart rate variability in conjunction
with my food and my sleep and all the
rest of that stuff than the hormones
tend to stay pretty good in line,
but if they start pushing anything,
if I start compromising sleep for me,
if I go to low carb too long,
particularly with some really hard
training,
then I will kind of get adrenalized and
I get all the signs and symptoms of
testosterone kind of dropping down and
whatnot.
Which is interesting because I know
you've played around with that and
seemed out some pretty good success in
quito.
Fueled rolling.
Yeah.
Well,
what I had was.
What fascinated me is I'm on
testosterone replacement therapy and
when I took my diet away from a high
carbohydrate diet to a much more high
fat diet,
ketogenic diet,
my testosterone levels were way up.
Interesting way up and not just me,
but a bunch of my friends who were also
on testosterone replacement therapy
reported the same thing where they said
like,
my friend john is stuffed,
doubled his,
his,
his levels doubled and he couldn't find
any other variability.
And it was the thing.
Was that just free testosterone or fleet
in total question?
Um,
I believe it was free.
Okay.
But what it,
what it is apparently is,
and please correct me if I'm wrong,
the precursors for testosterone are the
saturated fats and cholesterol in your
body produces testosterone from them,
right?
When you have an abundance of them and
you're in a healthy balance like you're
about,
it's not like you're consuming a
unhealthy foods.
When you get a healthy balance of those,
your body produces more testosterone
naturally.
Okay?
Okay.
Well,
and it's interesting and this is where
this stuff gets really complex,
but usually when people are on a lower
carb diet and this hormone called sex
hormone binding protein or sex hormone
binding globulin,
that increases and what that can do,
it can reduce the level of free
testosterone.
So your total testosterone may look
good,
the free testosterone may look great.
That's a not an uncommon thing to happen
on low carb diets.
But then the interesting side to that is
that the receptor sites,
which are really what matters in this
whole story,
the receptor site density for
testosterone increases so you may not
need as much to get the same effect that
you would otherwise have or if you have
a little bit more testosterone than
you're going to get an even greater
effect.
And so that receptor site density,
like what is causing that I don't fully
know.
Um,
but when people are on a lower carb
diet,
it does appear that anabolic hormones
have a more pronounced effect and what
they would have during a,
a higher carb period.
And I don't really know the mechanism
behind how that works,
but it definitely,
you seem to get,
you know,
if you have 100 units of testosterone or
estrogen in one person and they have a
certain number of a receptor sites and
then another person,
same hormonal level but more receptor
sites than they are going to get them
more potent.
Anabolic response out,
yeah,
so many variables and then when you take
into account what we've discussed
already about genetic variables and the
right bit,
different people respond differently to
that
hydrates and fats and proteins.
It is so difficult for people to find
the thing that works best for them.
Right?
Right.
For me it seems like quito or maybe a
little bit more carbs and quito is the
way to go.
Right.
You know,
but what I do is one of the big things
to do is have any of it laying right
here.
I supplement with exoticness ketones.
Okay.
Yeah,
and that seems to have a big effect on
me.
It,
it definitely puts me into a state of
ketosis.
I use something called key genics,
but I believe there's some other stuff
on the on the market,
but dom d'agostino,
who is a professor and what is it?
University of Florida,
and he is one of the foremost experts on
kido and he's coming on the podcast
soon.
We're working on finding a date,
but in the meantime,
his interview with tim ferriss is
amazing.
I think he's done twice a,
maybe more on tim show,
but that when he discusses it,
you kind of understand like what the
benefits of being on this high fat diet
are,
and then you also realize what,
what the compromise is that your body
has to make when you change it to a high
carbohydrate,
high sugar diet.
And one of the things that is a new
study that dr rhonda,
rhonda patrick sent me recently was the
dangers of saturated fats have been sort
of overstated a lot of it because of
that.
I'm sure you're aware that New York
times article about the sugar industry,
literally bing scientists lie in the 19
fifties and say that heart disease is
being called caused by saturated fats
and taking the blame off of sugar.
Right?
And they altered data and really fucked
with generations of people's ideas to
change the information that we receive
and fuck with people's heads.
But there was a recent study that showed
that,
um,
process sugar mixed with saturated is
actually
not healthy at all and it actually
perhaps could be more unhealthy than
processed sugar alone.
Right?
And it,
it really makes sense because if we over
consume carbohydrates in general than
we,
we fill up the liver,
glycogen in the liver starts converting
this into palmitic acid,
which is a saturated fat.
And that paul medic acid tends to make
us insulin resistant and indeed good
mechanisms behind that,
like there's good kind of engineering
there if we're eating a little bit more
of an ancestral type diet,
but when you throw a modern process diet
and sedentism and messed up circadian
rhythm,
you know,
not going to bed on time,
not getting enough,
a daylight sun,
then the whole mess ends up being really
pro inflammatory and very much moving
you towards this insulin resistant
profile.
Now what is it about sugar where when
you are not consuming it on a regular
basis,
um,
and then you take some time.
Like I've,
I've gotten like really strict ketogenic
for four or five months and then I'll go
off and have like a milkshake and fries
and I can't fucking believe how bad I
feel.
And I've got to think that there's,
my body just doesn't know what to do
with it anymore.
It doesn't,
um,
during the state of ketosis,
so you say normal time,
normally the brain runs off glucose,
but what's really normal,
like I,
for me normal is trying to look at this
from this ancestral template,
you know,
and so for eons,
humans and every other organism on the
planet didn't have consistent food and
because our brain is so big and it's so
metabolically active,
even though I think it's like two
percent of our body weight,
but 20 percent of the energy use,
it's really important that we protect
that.
And so The process of ketosis is a
workaround so that we don't have to
break down protein to convert it into
glucose.
To feed the brain.
We can break down body fat.
The body fat gets turned into ketone
bodies which are water soluble and can
go through the blood brain barrier and
that can fuel the brain in a really
effective way.
But when you do that,
what you are trying to do with spare
glucose,
just for the brain,
just for the red blood cells,
the few tissues that have to run on
glucose like they have no,
no other work around red blood cells,
and then some parts of the brain like so
some parts of the brain,
if you're on a really restricted sugar
diet,
they will suffer it initially until you
get ramped up into ketosis and then
you're fueling more.
The brain in the numbers vary.
Uh,
the somewhere between 70,
80 percent of the brain can shift over
fully to ketone body metabolism,
but the other 20 can't,
can't 20 to 30.
And we always,
even in ketosis,
we still have a blood glucose level
that's being metered out by the liver.
But what the body does is it creates
what's called a metabolic insulin
resistance where the muscles become
insulin resistant so that we don't use
glucose in the muscles were using free
acids and we're using ketone bodies.
So then you go and you've been ketotic
for awhile.
You have physiological insulin
resistance to support and maintain that
qi tonic state.
That's totally fine,
but then your first meal out of that is
like the milkshake,
you knoW,
a fries,
you know,
200 grams of carbohydrate and because
you're physiologically insulin
resistant,
it takes a massive amount of insulin to
be able to push that stuff into storage
and it will make you feel like death.
I feel terrible.
I always need a nap.
I feel like I have headaches and I'm
like,
what kind of a pussy if I become like,
what's happening here because I used to,
used to be easy for me.
Right.
And you know that there's some,
it's an interesting trade off because
you could make an argument that we
should be able to live like a cockroach
and like you just,
you know,
you bounce back and forth,
under ideal circumstances we would be
resilient and we could be able to shift
these fuel substrates.
And this is some of the argument for
like intermittent fasting where you
force your body to run off of fats and
maybe you do a carbohydrates every
couple of days or maybe earlier in the
day and then later in the day it's just
a fat and protein and then you fast
through part of the next day so that
you're forcing your body to run off fat
to produce some key tones,
maybe not at a level of full nutritional
ketosis.
But then also when you do drop in some
carbs,
your body can handle that and it doesn't
put you into that kinda like diabetic
blood sugar levels.
And,
and,
uh,
it's all really speculative.
I don't really know what the right
answer is with any of that stuff,
but it is interesting and it does kind
of call into question the,
you know,
how useful is chronic ketosis relative
to being able to cycle in and out of it.
And I don't have a good answer,
but I definitely feel best when I'm qi
tonic.
You feel best when your qi tonic,
but you tend to do a little bit higher
carbohydrate to fuel the jujitsu,
jujitsu.
So,
and that doesn't knock you out of a
state of ketosis as long as you've been
fairly consistent.
It does.
And I do.
So when I'm fully keto adapted,
the blood ketone levels are higher.
And also like if I needed to miss a
meal,
you know,
if I just didn't get breakfast,
lunch,
dinner,
and I want a full day,
it would be inconsequential,
like I would be a little hungry,
but it really wouldn't affect me.
That's the biggest benefit of opinions.
Huge.
And so when I do that 75 to 120 grams of
carbs to fuel the jujitsu,
I can't do that as easy,
like 10 hours and 12 hours in of uh,
you know,
uh,
so I sleep.
I'll sleep through the night.
So I've got a 12 hour fast then I get up
in,
if I tried to go to 6:00
PM that day,
I'd be hungry.
I wouldn't be totally broken down
dysfunctional like I was when I was know
insulin resistant sugar burner.
But it's not the same as being keto
adapted now.
Do you mess it all with exogenous
ketones?
I do a little bit,
but the ketone salts give me the trots.
So Yeah.
So those are kind of rough.
I do a lot of the,
a caveman coffee and then they're mct
oil and I'll actually mix that up with
peanut butter and then either a soy
lecithin or a sunflower less than
because it kind of a multifocal.
All that stuff.
So I'll mix it up together and then I'll
eat that and I get a decent point five
millimolar blood ketone level off of
that even though I'm eating some carbs
with it.
That's interesting.
So now you're your peanut butter is a
sugar free peanut butter natural peanut
butter peanut butter peanut butter.
People say,
oh jeff,
I'm going to just eat it by the tub and
while you will.
And then peanuts or are legumes.
And so there's a bunch of like super
hardcore paleo folks that are freaking
out and dying right now that I'm eating
peanut butter.
So now why don't paleo people like
peanuts?
What the fuck's wrong with them?
So legumes do have some,
what we call immunogenic properties.
They can irritate the immune system and
if you improperly prepare them then they
can make you really sick.
Like if you.
If you cooked some black beans or kidney
beans or something,
you didn't cook them enough and you
weighed them,
it can give you gas,
right?
It's like where you're shitting blood
essentially.
It's pretty pretty nasty stuff and these
are the anti predation chemicals that
are in grains and legumes,
but if you soak them overnight,
you pull off the rinse water,
maybe sprout them for a day and you
don't even have to do that involved.
Or if you cook them in a medium that has
a little bit of acid in it,
then it tends to break down these anti
nutrients and they're not nearly as
immunogenic,
but somebody who has serious gi problems
and this circles back again to that,
that small intestinal bacterial
overgrowth.
Somebody who has cbo,
somebody has some other gi probLems.
if they have an autoimmune condition,
grains and legumes may be something that
you want to minimize because it is
immunogenic.
For a lot of people,
and this is the success that we've seen
with this autoimmune paleo approach.
So I think that the,
the unfortunate thIng is on the one
hand,
there are a lot of people who dismissed
the power of limiting these foods in
people that would benefit their.
Like there's no science to support it
and they've never invested a minute
towards researching it.
So they're ignorant about that.
But then on the other side,
there's a whole group of people that
maybe they had success with this
autoimmune paleo protocol.
They had ulcerative colitis,
they had multiple sclerosis,
they had success for it.
Now they say that nobody can or should
eat these foods and you know,
I,
I've got to throw myself under the bus.
I've probably been that person for a
decade or longer,
you know,
but over the course of time,
just life it,
it's that jujitsu thing again,
you know,
where it's like the truth will pound you
and at some point you either get it or
you just become this like calcified old
turd and you can't learn or grow.
And over the course of time,
it just became obvious that if your gut
is healthy,
if all the cylinders are firing,
doing some grains and legumes is
probably not going to be a negative
problem for you,
but if you are a cop or a firefighter in
the military and you've historically
been able to eat these foods and then
you go to a shift work schedule and
you're under a massive amount of stress
because of an altered sleep wake cycle,
those foods that may have been okay may
no longer now be okay.
And so that's another piece that people
just need to remain open.
That something that's working for you
today may not work for you tomorrow.
And then you know,
something that worked for me may not
work for this other person.
It's kind of common sense,
but people just desperately in this
health,
wellness,
nutrition realm,
they want black or white,
yes or no binary stuff.
This is good,
that's bad.
And as much as I would,
it would make my life way simpler if
that was the case.
But it's just not like there's all this
variability in there.
Are you familiar with the dunning kruger
effect?
Yes.
Okay.
So yeah,
so dunning kruger effect,
like if you do like the x,
y axis,
the x axis is going out and this is time
and the y axis is your perceived
knowledge on a topic when you don't have
any time in a topic,
then you assume that you know everything
about it and they call it mount stupid.
And I spent a lot of time in mount
stupid and um,
as we all,
as we all have.
And then there's this low,
like low abv,
the dark teatime of the soul.
You know,
where you've been in it.
Yeah,
there we go.
And so as that stretches out,
then you get some,
hopefully some degree of aptitude,
but the,
as you learn more and more and more,
you're confident about any given topic
just starts going down more and more.
And I'm at this point now where I'm
like,
I don't know if I know anything about
any topic.
And I guess that that's kind of a good
process.
Ten years ago I was much more confident
about a whole host of things.
It's like there's a right answer and
there's a wrong answer,
and today I just really don't know.
Yeah,
there's a great expression about that.
As the lake of knowledge increases,
the shoreline of ignorance grows as
well.
Yeah.
I think dennis mckenna had to take onto
that.
As you increase the bonfire of
knowledge,
it exposes the greater level of
ignorance the light does.
It's a natural human tendency for some
strange reason to want to know
everything or to want to pretend you
know,
everything.
It's like a defensive mechanism or
something.
Definitely is a defensive mechanism and
it's just so appealing to to basically
put a fence around what your current
knowledge status and be like.
There it is.
We're good.
You know,
it's a really tough deal to just kind of
dangling the breeze and to hang that
sign,
you know?
good.
Until further notice.
Yeah,
and that's why today it's so weird
because you can find other people that
agree with you on that and they pump you
up and give you that confirmation bias
and they support each other and they get
together and make fun of everybody who's
not in the nose.
That hashtag woke.
Right?
Oh god.
And you know,
I had a lot of that like running across
fit type gym.
I would recommend this low carb paleo
type of approach and for people that
were insulin resistant,
overweight,
it worked amazingly well.
And then when I started working with
more mma oriented folks and a cross
fitters,
they,
it took a long time and breaking a lot
of people to figure out,
okay,
these people need some more carbs,
you know,
like they may not need as much as what
they've historically done,
but there's fully quito fuel process is
probably not going to work with them.
And it broke some people,
including myself.
What's very hard for people to wrap
their head around the idea that eating
fruit is not a good idea.
Like eating too much fruit could be bad
for you.
People are lIke,
what?
Right,
you can eat a banana and some
strawberries and some grapes and an
orange and I feel great and some people
might,
but there's a lot of people that can get
in the deep end of the,
the,
you know,
the blood sugar management story with
that.
Yeah.
That seems so counterintuitive to what
we've been told as kids.
Like you have some fruit,
it's good for you.
It tastes good and it's good for you.
You're like,
oh,
okay,
great.
it's good for you.
Well,
it's interesting.
We have these,
uh,
old variety crab apples on my property,
johnny appleseed kind of deal and that's
what apple's effectively used to be.
We can narrow those at each other.
Yeah,
we,
we make cider out of it and it turns,
turns pretty good for that.
But uh,
if you pull up like an image of what an
original banana looks like,
oh,
they're ridiculous.
Like seed.
Yeah.
It's tiny and it's all seeds and there's
hardly any edible structure to it.
And so if you look at most of the fruit
that was available kind of pre
agriculture and that,
that,
uh,
a selective breeding of fruit,
like it was much smaller,
wasn't as sweet.
And again,
it's not to say that you shouldn't have
any of that stuff,
but it's just,
there was a interesting piece that came
out of the uk where it was looking at
feeding kids fruit.
They were like,
let's,
let's recommend that these kids eat
fruit and the kids already had a hyper
caloric diet.
They were eating too much.
They were eating too many carbs and then
they threw fruit on top of it and
they're like,
wow,
adding fruit to this already shitty
overeating program made it worse,
you know?
And it was like there was going to be
some sort of magic that came out of
adding some fruit to this story.
Whereas the kids just needed to pull
more of the junk out and get some sort
of both caloric control land.
Some carbohydrate control is really
interesting.
Is there any fruit that is in its
original state?
Like maybe pomegranates,
they kinda berries are pretty pretty,
you know,
uh,
blueberries,
blackberries,
so sorts of things while they're pretty
similar to that.
Sweet.
Not that sweet.
No different.
Different flavor.
Yeah.
No.
Yeah,
I've,
I've picked them like in the wild,
like in the back country,
like a blueberry and it just like,
hmm,
this is not bad,
but it's not spectacular.
It's not what you're used to.
Yeah.
Uh,
but oranges clearly they have been
fucked with,
right?
Yeah.
Apple's like we were on a trip once and
bought these apples and they were
literally like the size of a softball
and you bite into it.
It's like the most delicious dessert you
could ever have.
Like this can't be a fucking real
regular apple.
Right.
Something's been going on.
Or noble apple.
I mean,
how much of our food,
I mean especially at our fruit,
how much of it is genetically altered?
It's got to be massive amounts and you
know,
that gmo story.
I'm in a spot where I usually piss
everybody off about it because I am way
less concerned about genetic
modification of these things and more
concerned about some of the business
practices that happen,
like we've been doing selective breeding
for thousands of years and that has
modified the genetics back to the wolf,
turning into dog story like that,
tomatoes,
everything and without.
I mean the classic thoughts of franken
foods meaning laboratory,
some sort of injection into that's not
what's going on.
Selective breeding for the most part,
most of it's selective breeding and the
thing about gmo to is the apologist for
it.
Like when you look at the results that
you get with the gmo,
the genetic modification,
it's really unimpressive.
I mean it's not like dramatically
increasing yields.
What it inevitably is doing is creating
something that's usually more resistant
to roundup than what the last thing was
wound up being that pesticide foster,
yeah.
Yeah.
Which is legitimately some pretty nasty
stuff and so it doesn't really seem to
be working any type of magic as far as
feeding the world or anything like that.
It is creating a funnel where in order
to grow this thing,
you need more chemical fertilizer input,
you need more pesticide input and it
just seems to be this feed forward
mechanism on that.
And so I'm,
I'm really from a health standpoint,
I'm not that freaked out aBout gmos just
as a baseline,
but from a really shady business
practice.
I'm not a big fan from a,
uh,
actually moving the needle on food
production.
It's really unimpressive to me.
So I,
my position on gmos usually just makes
everybody mad because I'm not really
jumping into either one of these,
these camps,
whole hog with food production in
general.
When you look at these gigantic large
scale farms that has,
that is one of the most unnatural things
you're ever going to see in life.
Right?
There's giant cornfields,
right?
That's so unnatural,
monocrop.
Yeah.
And not only that monocrop,
but those are genetically modified crops
and you know,
and you want to kill off all the weeds,
spraying your genetiCally modified mono
crops with some shit that kills off
everything,
but you're genetically modified model
crops and who knows what that
consequences on the human body will.
So a roundup is now being suggested or
has been suggested for a long time as a
mitochondrial disruptor,
similar to that antibiotic story.
So tHis is where people,
you know the last questions about like,
well what about this gluten intolerance
thing?
Like people didn't have it 50 years ago,
why is it going on now?
And we really don't know,
but maybe it's antibiotics,
maybe it's changes in the gut
microbiome,
but a lot of this stuff seems to have a
mitochondrial dysfunction piece to it.
Parkinson's,
alzheimer's,
type two diabetes.
They all seem to have mitochondrial
dysfunction elements to them.
The mitochondria is not producing energy
the way that it should.
And back again to that point about being
flexible with our fuel systems,
people seem to becoming inflexible in
their fuel systems.
and this key todrick state may be the
default that we're able to go back to to
be able to maintain some degree of
health and it also seems to press a
reset button in the mitochondria where
we get apoptosis and cell death and
abnormal cells,
but the need for people to shift towards
a lower carb diet may be reflective of
some changes in the environment where
we're being made sick by things like
glyophosphate or maybe an over
aggressive antibiotic use and then the
thing that we need to default back to to
be able to be healthy as some sort of a
low carb or ketogenic diet.
Now,
when you're talking about foods and
foods that people eat and breads and
gluten deficiencies or gluten
intolerances,
what about sprouted breads and what are
the.
What are the difference between
something like a zucchini bread and say
like a wonder bread?
Yeah,
so within the zucchini bread,
they soak these grains,
pour off the water,
let them sprout,
and in that sprouting process,
the enzymes that are released tend to
break up the gluten and gluten proteins.
And for a lot of people who are gluten
intolerant with like a piece of wonder
bread or standard french bread,
they could eat something like these
equal bread.
Not everybody can.
I can't.
Like if I had a piece when I hit your
bathroom,
it would need a priest and an exorcism
that you would break it over and you
know I was never.
We've looked at celiac is a gluten
intolerance,
but if I get some sort of a wheat
exposure and it's to the degree that
like if a steak is grilled on a grill
and somebody grilled french toast on the
grilled the day before,
I'm going to be sick from it.
So I'm like the canary in the coal mine
on it sucks.
It's amazing.
Fascinating.
But does it have any bay?
Does it have any effect on nutrient
absorption because of the celiacs?
A big part of it is when you're exposed
to that bread,
it's not just that you go to get
diarrhea,
but they.
The nutrients are not getting into your
system.
Right?
Because of the intestinal permeability.
The way I got into all this stuff,
I was really,
really sick.
And had all sort of colitis and I'm
about 175 pounds right now when my
ulcerative colitis was at its worst,
I was 130 pounds.
So I was 40 pounds skinnier.
How old are you?
I'm 45 now.
But now how old were you then at that
point?
I was like 27,
28.
oh wow.
Yeah.
So look like death.
I,
I looked like concentrAtion camp deal.
yeah.
And it was just malabsorption,
like I couldn't absorb anything.
I was shoveling food down and for me at
that point it was a high,
it was a grain and legume based kind of
a vegan diet,
which for me was just not working for
that point in my life.
Living in seattle,
not having any sun like that was a
really,
really bad move forming it.
But I will say this,
this was also on the heels of getting
and resolving at least to degree grd.
So I think that parasitic infection,
low vitamin d levels,
bad sleep,
bad circadian rhythm,
like all that stuff fed into it.
And so for combination there.
yeah,
if you want to get taken down at the
necaps that was a good way to do it.
And to cure giardia,
what did they give you?
Might trinitas hall,
which is a antimicrobial that they use
for things like grd and then also some
of the rk bactor bacteria.
so,
so these kind of parasitic bacteria type
things.
And does that have an effect on
mitochondria as well?
The same way the antibiotics do I.
It's not the same way,
but it is a mitochondrial disruptor as
well.
Yeah.
What,
what is a pro mitochondria supplement?
Is there anything then?
so like resveratrol,
fasting,
ketosis,
those things all tend to flip some
switches in the mitochondria that make
them healthier and more robust,
variable varying things rather on a
reservoir trawl being absorbable,
it's very difficult to absorb it.
Yeah.
What is the best way?
I'm usually,
it's some sort of an emulsification with
fat and,
and uh,
you know,
life realized and so it's,
it's quite fat soluble.
So if you can get it mixed into a fatty
matrix,
then it enhances the absorption.
But it does seem to.
And,
and you know,
most of this data is petri dish type
data,
so we really don't know if it's having
great effect in the body and then
there's another layer to this.
A Ton of these polyphenolics don't
really enter the body or they don't
enter the body as the original chemical.
They get modified by the gut bacteria
and then either the gut bacteria
manufacturer completely different
chemical or some sort of downstream
chemical is what enters the body,
or it may just interface with the gut
lining and then the gut sends out
different signaling molecules that then
affects the rest of the body.
Wow.
So it depends upon the healthiness of
your gut bacteria.
It that's a massive impact.
it has a massive impact on whether or
not that [inaudible] or other similar
nutrients get an just pharmaceuticals in
general.
Like when you look at people going on a
heart med or you know,
different things like depending what
something that their understanding is
not only do we have genetic differences,
but the differences in the gut
microbiome may have a really profound
influence in the way that people respond
to supplements.
Pharmaceuticals,
yeah.
Yeah.
It's just so much to take in for the
person and the average person is
listening to this that wants to sort of
optimize their health.
There's so many.
There should Be like.
It's kind of amazing.
I guess it's a lot of this is because
this is a fairly new discipline in terms
of the last few decades and guys like
you who are on the forefront of it.
I've done some person and chris kresser
who's gone through his own deal.
He was a macrobiotic vegan point in time
and now he tells you to eat liver and,
and you and you should see pictures of
it.
He ended up getting a really nasty gut
bug in I think the Philippines and um,
pictures of him before.
He was like jacked super thick legs,
like thick neck tie boxer and now he's
pretty wavy and he's never really been
able to put all the weight back on and
kind of get back to is as robust as what
he was before that.
But it was another situation where maybe
some irritation to the gut because of
the diet and indefinitely this
infectious agent,
whatever the bug was that he caught,
just crushed him.
There should be some sort of a place
that you could go like a string of
places,
you know,
where you can open them up in major
cities and metropolitan areas where
someone can go and find out like what is
the right stuff to do?
I went to this one,
they did some blood work on me and the
lady told me,
avocados just don't agree with you.
I'm like,
fuck off.
That is so dumb.
TheRe's not a god I've.
I eat avocados all the time.
They're great.
There's just trying to come up with some
sort of ridiculous blood test that shows
the avocados.
I'm like,
that's not real,
right.
That can't be real,
can it?
There's not much again,
that that stuff gets really.
Especially avocado.
I know it's like damn avocado.
So if somebody has intestinal
permeability of for whatever reason,
then you can become reactive unlike the
igg antibody testing.
But it does.
But the problem is not the food
specifically.
The problem is that you have gut
permeability,
so if they fix that gut permeability,
then you're no longer really going to
react to the food because the food
doesn't get into your body.
Then you break it down into the protein,
into the amino acids and fatty acids in
the the constituent carbs,
and so the immunogenic properties that
it had before,
don't really matter because it's in your
gut and when the contents are inside to
get.
It's outside the body.
Is there any test that they can do with
your blood that would show that in any
way and is there any way that avocados,
one of the healthiest food known to man
could possibly be something you should
avoid?
Avocados are a not uncommon allergens,
so some people do develop allergies to
avocado seed essentially with that fruit
around it.
So there are some immunogenic proteins
to it.
It would have a pretty obvious reaction
than if you were allergic to chocolate
again,
and this is where the reaction wouldn't
be grabbing another chip and dip it in
the guacamole.
That's awesome.
Yeah,
and usually it's something like foggy
headedness or a gi issue or you know,
like joint creakiness or something like
that.
Creakiness the joints actually
physically make.
They just don't feel so.
Yeah.
So it feels like they're.
yeah.
Yeah.
What about sugar causes that
inflammation?
Because that is a big factor with people
that have injuries even if it's not
injuries,
if they have joint pain,
like knee pains,
back pains.
I've had this conversation with people
and I got it from a chiropractor.
She said,
believe it or not,
like gluten insensitivity,
just reducing gluten and becoming gluten
free will change the way injuries hurt
like back injuries.
And I thought well that sounds like some
hippie bullshit.
And so this was many years ago when I
started getting into this idea of
inflammatory foods that are affecting
the way your body and your joints
particular field,
but she only took it to the point of
gluten.
Right?
And then it wasn't a sugar thing for
her.
And then once I started looking into
sugar,
I'm like,
oh,
these are all foods that cause
inflammation.
Well,
what is happening?
What causes it?
What?
How does sugar or high sugar processed
sugar diet,
how does that cause inflammation?
So a couple of different mechanisms that
can happen here.
We we definitely understand that the
sugar can feed bacteria,
both good and bad bacteria.
If most of the bacterial masto should be
occurring in the colon,
like pretty far south,
and if we eat a diet that's really
deficient in fiber,
high in refined carbohydrates,
all carbohydrates get absorbed early and
so there's not actually any food for the
bacteria that should be living in the
colon.
So these bacteria tend to move more,
more upward in the gi tract.
And this is where we get small
intestinal bacterial overgrowth.
Sibo is a pro inflammatory process,
so that's one way that we can get
inflammation out of that.
Another way is just when we get really
wild swings in blood sugar,
that tends to be a pro inflammatory
process.
So just the upregulation of insulin,
particularly if it's over a chronic
process that can be a pro inflammatory
experience.
And then the other pieces,
you know,
if you start getting cortisol released
in response to blood sugar crashes
because you get hypoglycemic and you're
trying to ping the liver to release some
more glucose,
that can be a pro inflammatory
processes,
the inflammation,
what's the physical reaction?
Like what is happening when you say
inflammation?
So there's a bunch of different
mediators there,
so you've got different cytokines.
These chemicals like interleukin one,
interleukin six that are turning on
typically immune cells and then other
cells in the body are being effected as
Well,
but it's usually some sort of immune
cell response which then they in their
process and doing what they do,
they tend to release chemicals,
cytokines,
and in similar chemicals that it can
turn into a feed forward mechanism.
So the,
you know,
it's ultimately chemical messaging that
can turn on other inflammatory processes
in cells that are nearby and also the
immune cells themselves.
So that is causing these joints to be
painful and then back to the joint.
So whenever we do anything,
any type of workout,
even just exercise.
So.
So this is important,
important point to make to inflammation
in and of itself isn't necessarily bad,
it's the amount and type and placement
and all that type of stuff.
So exercise is a proinflammatory
process.
It's what we call a hormetic stress.
So we get a little bit of this stress,
ideally an appropriate dose and the body
senses
this stress and then it makes us
stronger so that we can cope with a
subsequent exposure to this.
But if our sYstem is already pro
inflamed from poor diet,
inadequate sleep,
gut permeability,
what have you,
than these little,
you know,
tears and bumps and bruises and
adhesions that we get from physical
activity,
they never really heal because our body
is allocating resources to deal with the
inflammation in the gut and are kind of
over hyped up inflammatory response and
it doesn't have the resources to deal
with the inflammation in our joints and
our muscles and whatnot.
Hm.
Interesting.
So what,
what are the best anti inflammatories
supplements or foods that people can
take?
Because ibuprofen is something you
should pretty clearly avoid now using
sparingly.
Yeah,
and this is for,
for people that are not listening or
that are listening to this,
that are not aware,
it's been shown over the last few years
in particular that ibuprofen is exactly
pretty dangerous.
Um,
and,
and can cause a host heart attack.
Yeah,
it increases like 60 percent of strokes.
I'm a good friend of mine,
cameron hanes,
who's a marathon runner and an ultra
marathon runner.
You used to take it every day and he was
always in pain.
Right.
And what was fascinating was I did a
podcast with rhonda patrick where she
talked about the dangers of it and
talked about how horrible it is for your
gut bacteria,
right?
And that that could in fact be causing
the actual inflammation that you're
trying to fight with the ibuprofen.
Then this continual cycle and lupe got
him off of it and his Joint pain went
away.
Right?
Which is just insane.
You think,
how does this happen?
How does this guy has joint pain all the
time and he's taken ibuprofen for the
joint pain.
He thinks it's just a fact of life in
the joint.
Pain is an inflammatory process and he's
taking an anti inflammatory,
which you would think,
oh,
this is probably a win,
but it,
you know,
in the complexity is kind of kind of
crazy.
But yeah,
and interestingly it seems to be gut
bacteria mediated.
Now what,
like when a person does have some sort
of an issue,
like a headache or some sort of a
swollen joint or some,
some pain,
is there anything that you can take that
has anti inflammatory properties?
It doesn't have the negative health
consequences,
you know.
And for me,
this is my,
my own,
I'll maybe give you some of my own
triage with this stuff.
Like I had an l four l five disc injury
about 15 years ago doing crossfit at
crossfit hq of all places.
It was pretty,
pretty catastrophic.
But um,
uh,
what was the disc bulging with?
So the first workout was 75 glute ham
sit ups,
which you know,
you're on like a glute ham developer and
you're doing a super long range of
movement sit up.
And I ended up with abdo.
Like basically my stomach was inflamed.
It was inflamed for like 12 days.
It was about 13 days later.
We're pulling abdo abdo instead of
rhabdo like the rhabdomyolysis maya
licenses.
When you overtrain your body literally
starts breaking down your muscle tissues
and you had pick up your kidneys and you
can die.
Yeah,
so I had kind of a compartmental
syndrome with this.
It was just in the abs,
but it was bad.
So my app is just overworked.
Your abs massively overworked.
I mean there was no up no ramp up.
This is the first time I've seen this
movement and I did 75.
Yeah,
it was ridiculous.
So I'm 12.
Thirteen days later we were supposed to
pull max dead lifts.
My abs were still not healed and I'd
like for 65 on the bar.
I was just passing my knees and my abs
just failed.
And so I had this like fluxion injury
with a lot of load.
It,
a very precarious spot.
And I know for l five disc injury,
it's bulging.
It's not ruptured,
but if I don't mobilize,
if I sit too much,
if,
if my hip flexors get tight,
it will get super cranky.
So I will get to spots,
like if I'm working a lot where I have
to take some ibuprofen and all.
So you have this injury still to this,
but yeah,
like it's way better in general,
but every once in a while I can piss it
off pretty good.
Have you ever used a reverse hyper?
Yes.
Yeah.
And it definitely helps.
Definitely helps.
I mean when I,
when I stay on my mobility maintenance
cycle,
I am good to go,
but when I get super busy when I'm
traveling,
you know,
if I have to sleep in a weird bed or
something like it's tends to be a
cumulative thing to adds up over like
two weeks.
And then I can get kind of a back flip
for people who,
Uh,
someone just asked about this on twitter
yesterday,
the reverse hypers and machine created
by a guy named louie simmons who is a
really famous power lifter and a
completely insane person who,
if you want to listen to the podcast,
jamie and I did with him at his place,
west side barbell,
he's,
he's a fucking nut but genius in making
this machine that out allows active
decompression of the spine.
I'm a big fan of it.
Um,
do you do any sort of spinal
decompression exercises?
So both,
uh,
you know,
kind of the,
the inversion board and then also just
um,
hanging.
I'll actually use some,
you know,
weight lifting straps and go out on a
pull up bar,
hands together and it'll hang for like
three minutes at a shot.
So we'll get to rassic decompression and
then also.
So it's not grip dependent,
right?
I do thAt,
but I do it with the grip.
I just,
because I feel like for jujitsu and for
all the other things,
I need strong hand.
So I'll just kill two birds with one
stone.
Yeah.
For that I'm on wanting such a training
stimulus for loosening my thoracic
girdle and everything that it's gonna.
It's gonna wipe out my grip.
My grip would fail way before I would
get that kind of thoracic opening.
Yeah.
Did you ever think maybe you should work
your grip to grip?
But I,
I mean we're talking about it.
It's a fairly fat bar also that I have.
Okay.
And so I'm just using that as a little
bit of a bridge for that,
but I mean like there's a real benefit
in having a federal bar,
right?
Uh,
it,
you can get strength from here rather as
strange.
I think again,
like this variety,
you know,
like getting as much variety as
possIble.
I love rope climbs.
Like if I had one pulling movement I was
going to use,
it would probably be a rope climb like
that.
Interesting.
Yeah.
And you get this unilateral movement
but you're also like,
you're,
you get pack involvement.
Lattes are rated the whole thing and and
as you pull it in it tends to look a lot
like a lot of the positions and the
strength in,
In jujitsu and so you also,
as part of it,
you can work these lock off says as part
of the the transition.
So for me it just ends up getting more
development across my back,
my arms,
my shoulders in one movement than I
could get from any other type of polling
activity.
That makes sense.
Now
as far as like lower back decompression,
do you ever do that one where you're
hanging from your waist?
Only from the waist down.
I love that one.
That one seems to isolate the lower
spine.
What is the name of that thing that we
have in the back?
Jamie?
The one that does that one.
Spinal decompression machine that we put
together back there.
The one with your feet,
the hangups thing?
No,
not the hangup one but the other one.
The one that you kinda looks like it
looks like a roman setup chair and so,
but it's just for decompression and you
just leaned forward and it just,
it seems to target directly the lower
back,
much better than just the ankle ones.
The ones from the ankle,
I feel like my legs are holding a little
too much and I'm hanging on.
I'm controlling it a little too much.
Right.
Whereas this one,
I can completely let go.
Well in some of the,
the uh,
the gravity boots,
like they were finding that people were
getting like laxity and their knees,
like the knees were giving away before
you really decompress the back.
THat makes sense.
Yeah,
that makes sense.
But,
but also some of that lacks in the
knees.
Probably believed some knee pressure on
some folks as well.
Sort of like how shoulder hangs releases
a lot of shoulder pain and some people.
Right,
right,
right.
Yeah,
totally.
Totally.
Yeah.
But back to your question about the,
uh,
any inflammatories,
like if I get a really spicy backflow or
I will do 800 milligrams of ibuprofen,
but I'll hit it once and then I'm good.
Do you feel any adverse effects because
you don't do it a lot,
do you feel like,
do you take it and then feel any health
consequences?
I,
I don't,
but I mean one of the primary health
consequences as killing over from a
heart attack or stroke.
So,
you know,
but it's one of those things where I've
played with it and once it gets in that,
you know,
I can ice it and I can do stem and all
that stuff helps.
But it's just like,
man,
if I can get one targeted bolus of,
of ibuprofen 800 milligrams,
I hit it once and it just drops it down
and then,
you know,
I,
it,
it changes the whole thing from being a
two day issue to like a 12 day issue
because otherwise they'll just kind of
drag on and,
and I've just gotten to a point where if
I really get myself into a bad spot with
my mobility or,
or just getting this thing pissed off,
then it's like,
okay,
I've just got to do this.
But then beyond that there's this
product from a new chapter called ziflow
mend and it's really,
really pretty slick as far as,
uh,
an anti inflammatory.
It pulls,
um,
some ginger extract.
Curcumin,
they do a super critical extract on
it and that stuff is pretty legit.
And that can,
for a lot of people,
like I haven't found that it works as
well on that pain and inflammation
reduction when my back gets really
spicy.
But it's pretty darn good in everything
that's in it.
You could make some arguments.
It would be pretty beneficial over the
long haul.
Like,
it's uh,
uh,
these uh,
cox,
two pathways modifiers,
but they,
it does it in a different way than what
the ibuprofen does.
Is it dose dependent?
I mean,
is there a,
like a point of diminishing returns
where you get 800 milligrams is like the
magic number for ibuprofen?
They say you shouldn't go over that.
Right.
But is it something like that with this
stuff?
I don't know.
I don't know,
like they have a recommended dose on it,
but I haven't really played around with
that,
but I mean everything usually has some
sort of a,
you know,
kinetics like dose response curve with
it.
So I would assume so.
Yeah.
Yeah,
that's what I was wondering.
I'm like,
what if you took our hyper doses?
I haven't tried that.
I have not tried that because it's all
natural stuff,
rigHt?
Like,
curcumin is not really dangerous in
larger doses.
Is it a,
I don't know about the tox toxicology on
that,
you know,
like,
um,
uh,
just because it's natural doesn't
necessarily mean that it's non toxic
arsenic.
Yeah.
So that's,
that's interesting.
Um,
I w that is an interesting idea.
I haven't really thought about going
beyond what the recommended is on that.
Yeah,
I would wonder if that would ramp it up.
Other than that,
what about aspirin?
Aspirin has some benefit.
Aspirin has some benefit,
but it's.
It's kind of an interesting mixed bag
too late to take enough of it to get a
really potent effect.
Like you would like if somebody had a
back spasm or something like that.
You're looking at the potential of gi
bleeding.
You have a really potent blood thinning
effects,
so I mean aspirins a little bit dodgy in
in that regard,
that really acute deal that you're.
You're trying to manage,
but it is a possibly interesting side
note.
Aspirin like a baby aspirin a day.
there's some studies that have suggested
that women taking that baby aspirin a
day.
It could reduce breast cancer
potentiality by like 70 percent because
of the antiangiogenic effects of the
aspirin.
Now I've read some things about the
ketogenic diet and cancer and that is
very fascinating to me about having
these high fat,
Low complex carbohydrates,
low simple carbohydrate diets can have a
great benefit on reducing the fuel that
cancer needs to stay alive.
It's,
I would say it's at least twofold.
It's probably multifactorial there,
but so on the one hand,
certain types of cancer tend to
preferentially run on glucose and so if
you can limit the glucose,
they don't really do well with fats or
proteins as a fuel source,
so you can limit that.
Not all cancers falling into this
category.
That was some cancers are super
metabolically flexible and they can use
just about anything as a fuel source,
so there's a benefit for potentially
breast,
colon,
prostate,
glioblastoma,
a couple of other endothelial derived
cancers that just directly that
reduction in glucose level may be really
beneficial.
There was another layer to it though
that that low glucose environment and
that shift towards ketosis tends to set
up this kind of stress response,
so we actually have a little bit of
oxydative stress occurring in the
mitochondria and normal tissue.
Do great with that,
but cancerous tissue does not,
so it's a little bit of an irritant and
what they're doing right now,
what they're studying is getting folks
ramped up on a ketogenic diet so that
you get that hormetic stress response.
You're limiting glucose and then they
will have people fast immediately before
chemo or radiation.
so this is still doing some conventional
therapies,
but that fasting state that while you're
also in ketosis,
it reduces your pool of this substance
called glutathione,
which is our normal antioxidant defense
network.
So interestingly,
and maybe counterintuitively,
they're trying to reduce your
antioxidant pool and get it down to a
bare minimum.
Then when they whack you and the cancer
with the chemo and the radiation,
the cancer is more prone to die because
it doesn't have antioxidant defense
mechanisms to keep it going.
So it's a,
it's an interesting thing because a lot
of,
uh,
people in the kind of alternative cancer
treatment scene,
you know,
they'll start dosing people on super
high antioxidants with the,
the thought that some of the etiology of
cancer may be driven by free radicals
by,
by oxidative damage.
And there may be some truth to that,
but it's kinda like the,
the horses out of the barn at this
point,
they're kind of tackling it in the wrong
way and even when they're using high
dose vitamin c,
they're using it intravenously and even
though vitamin c is touted as an
antioxidant,
it can be a pro oxidated high substances
and so are at high concentrations.
So what,
maybe a situation where you get the
glutathione pool depleted,
you hit these people with high dose
vitamin c and then they maybe do
hyperbaric oxygen where they go into a,
a,
a pressurized canister and they,
they do pure co two and that increases
the oxidative stress and that may be
another adJunctive treatment to this.
But that's all of these different
mechanisms that are kind of an outgrowth
of the key to genic diet going on in the
background.
Wow.
Um,
do you mess around with cryotherapy at
all?
Not a ton.
I mean,
I,
I live on a little three acre farm and,
and a rino.
And so it's cold frequently and I have
like a tub of water and never once while
when I buy sack up I'll go out there and
sit in it.
But it's so cold water,
it's not like,
you know,
throw ice in there anything.
Well,
I mean there's usually for much of the
year there's a little layer of ice on
the top of it.
And so I've got to like chisel that out
and then you climb in and out of climate
and measure the temperature.
Now,
I mean it's,
it's,
uh,
it's somewhere slightly above freezing
because,
you know,
it's got an inch or two of ice on top of
it.
But after you add rhonda patrick on
here,
um,
I kind of opted
more for the,
a hot sauna kind of deal with this.
I'm like,
dude,
that's a lot.
That's way easier than it seems really
positive here.
Yeah.
And I've been doing that after jujitsu
and on the days when I can pull that
off,
my recovery is amazing.
It's almost like I pressed the reset
button that day and although I got the
benefit of jujitsu,
I didn't have any of the downside.
It is crazy and I didn't experience that
when I would do a cryo immersions after
exercise.
Like I felt better kind of,
you know,
when the first maybe hour or two after a
hard workout during the cold water
immersion,
but then a day or two later like I was
still sore and joint creaky and all that
stuff.
Whereas with the sauna you get,
it's not an infrared sauna,
it's just like this hot as balls sought
140 degrees plus and I would sit in
there as long as I could 15,
20 minutes and man,
wHen when I finally break and I want
out,
it's like if there was an old person in
front of me getting out of there,
I would push them to panic.
Getting out of there.
Yeah,
no.
Is there a differentiation in your body
between a steam shower and a sauna?
Like when you get into one of those hot
steam showers and it's 135 degrees and
your data,
is it good because it's heat response,
right?
That's really what's going to spawn heat
shock proteins.
Yeah,
I know it did.
Rhonda patrick would know that one.
I do not know it.
It seems like for me that air can be
hotter in.
It's interesting though because water
can confers or,
or removes a heat like 30 times faster
than air does.
So like uh,
you know,
so um,
you could heat or cool the Body much
faster with water then you came with
eric clearly.
And so I'm wondering,
you know,
would you need water that's as hot as
the air to get the same type of
temperature elevation in your body or is
just the skin being exposed,
exposed to air temperature and it's like
an oven.
Is that,
is there something kind of cool with
that?
Like I,
I don't know,
that's a good question for that one too,
rhonda.
Yeah,
I'll make a note of that.
Yeah.
Um,
what about,
uh,
other forms of recovery post workout and
found anything to be beneficial?
Are you messing around at all with like
those hard balls?
Like those wad balls?
I do some stuff like that.
Like I,
so I followed this gymnastics bodies
program that I wanted to ask you about
that.
Yeah.
And it's really good and they have so
they have the strength work as part of
this whole thing pressing and pulling
all kinds of trunk work and everything.
But each strength movement has a
mobility movement paired with it.
So it's,
it's really interesting because as you
get stronger doing this stuff,
there's a tendency to get tighter so
they just kind of bake the mobility
movement into the cake with that.
But then they also have a three day a
week stretching sequence once the front
splits,
once the side splits.
And then the other one is thoracic
mobility for like a back bend.
And so I just kind of punch the time
clock on that like each day have some
strength and mobility work that I do
with that three days a week.
I do the um,
the dedicated stretching sequence,
I tend to do it with my daughters,
they're like three and five and so we
just get into the floor and you know,
it's just a shit show in there with them
also,
but it's a ton of fun and we'll hit that
like three days a week and that's been
really good.
I'm a meditation app,
like doing something like brainwave,
the binaural beats.
I'm so wound tight and kind of type a
that if I can just like sit down,
go outside,
look at the trees,
do five minutes on that thing,
do some kind of cyclic breathing.
That's amazing for me.
Like that is a really,
really good system reset for me.
have you done any isolation tank work?
I have done some isolation take away.
We tried to get me,
uh,
to go out to torrance last time when I
was here and I couldn't make it happen.
I've done that since I've done that.
Yeah.
So tell me what you've been doing and
how often.
I don't do it often.
It's usually when I'm traveling,
there is a place in reno now,
like it's just kind of getting into reno
and all over the country now.
it is amazing.
I had a guy apprOached me with a,
a,
an idea for a,
a pretty legit business model around
this and we were kind of looking at some
people putting some money into it and
then I heard that massage envy was going
to open up a,
uh,
you know,
the float tanks and they're everywhere.
Like there's massage envy on like every
corner.
And so I was like,
okay,
data that backed out of that because you
didn't think that it would be profitable
that way.
I thought it'd be really easy to get out
maneuvered by a multi offering,
kind of kind of,
you know.
But that makes sense.
Yeah.
Massage and float all in one location.
And if they sell weed to float tanks,
plus weed is like the greatest thing in
the world for relaxation,
right?
Yeah.
Yup.
In reno now load Nevada is now.
Remember on board with that Nevada.
Yeah.
The longest time to vita was one of the
strictest places in the world.
You if you got caught with a joint,
you went to jail for something like
seven years.
It was really crazy.
It,
it's a interesting environment because
you have like brothels around there,
you have the gambling,
but then there was this pretty like
draconian approach to uh,
you know,
like really minor drug offenses that
they should be offensive at all is.
Yeah,
it's pretty ridiculous.
now,
have you messed around at all with cbd
oil or cbd,
which is non psychoactive but has
tremendous beneficial properties for
anti-inflammation?
I have not.
And it's one of those things that's on
the list to do.
Yeah.
Get on that.
Because you would think that with
someone when I was asking you about a
anti-inflammation,
things like cbd apparently has profound
effects.
You know,
what's interesting about cbd is that
everything that you would think is good
about kind of a paleo ketogenic diet,
sleeping well,
exercising,
right?
Cbd does it effectively.
Now it doesn't work the sAme in every
single person and you need to kind of
play around with that.
So there's some caveats with it,
but when you just look at the
pharmacology,
you look at the research on it and you
look at all this other cool stuff that's
been done,
you know,
by,
by dietary interventions elsewhere in
lifestyle interventions.
Then the cbd oil hits all of those,
those pieces.
So yeah,
it's kind of amazing that that plant was
illegal for so long and still isn't a
lot of places and still it's federally
and there's so many benefits to it in a
non psychoactive benefits folks doesn't
have anything to do with your mind.
You know,
you just want an excuse to goodheart,
hard fucking loser.
That really doesn't even get you high.
Cbd is don't do a damn thing.
It does apparently alleviate anxiety and
some breaks,
right?
Yeah.
How much oF that is anxiety is dependent
or caused by inflammation?
They just had some great studies that
we're looking at a alterations in gut
microbiome and inflammatory status and
depression and anxiety.
And it was basically if they shifted
things such that the gut microbiome
looked healthier,
the depression anxiety basically
disappeared and then,
you know,
it could shift the other way.
And it's interesting again where if you
add something,
so not everybody's going to change her
diet and,
and like I advocate for that and push
and shove,
but the reality is like our world,
it's sent up and incentivized to not do
that.
Like the big junk food manufacturers
they study how to make this stuff
addictive.
Like what's the laY's potato chip line,
but you can't eat just one.
You know?
I was like,
I'll take that thing to the bank all day
long so you can ridicule people fat,
shame,
do all this stuff.
But there's a reality that our modern
world is set up to work exactly against
our genetics.
So what do we do then?
Well,
you could have something like cbd oil
where you put it in a little bite of
chocolate and the person has one or two
times a day or whatever the dosing
regimen is and maybe it puts their all
sort of colitis and remission.
Maybe their depression is gone.
And then maybe if we get them moving in
a good direction and they don't feel
like shit,
then maybe we can say,
okay,
let's now get some diet changes in
there.
Let's get you going to bed earlier.
If you are gonna,
stay up and work.
Put on some blue blockers so it doesn't
mess with your sleep patterns as much,
but it's a really accessible,
inexpensive,
a no risk proposition that could have
some really huge benefits for people.
Yeah.
I think that what you said too,
that this system is sort of set up to
get people to eat these crappy foods and
make them incredibly available and very
difficult to pass up.
And once you start eating them,
you consume on a daily basis.
Your body starts craving them.
You get addicted to them.
I was at the supermarket the other day
and I was under the influence and I was
always wandering through the aisles.
It was one of those weird moments where
I went,
is this always been like this?
I was just looking at these cans of
food.
Everything's can write.
And I was thinking this is all food,
but it can last forever and like is not
supposed to last forever.
The whole idea is supposed to grow it.
You take it out of the ground,
it's alive,
you eat it and then you're healthy.
And then I was looking at this food that
was like just filled with preservatives
and canned and these packages and
plastic bags of it.
And I was like,
this is so.
It's so strange
that this is the prevalent food because
it's so easy to store.
It's so easy to ship.
It's so easy to have for sale.
You put a barcode on the package and
you're good to go.
But this is not really.
I mean you can eat it,
it's food kind of.
Right?
But it's not really food food.
The real food is on the edges.
The real food is where the vegetables
are and where the meats are and where
the eggs are.
That stuff in the middle.
And those aisles where he just sees
bright colored cans,
they would.
It was so weird.
It was like a little kid's toy store,
right?
Like,
because I was high.
So I was wandering through the aisle and
I'm looking at all these different
colors on it.
This is so weird.
It's like trying to draw me in with
smiley faces on the cans and on the
plastic bags.
But it's,
we,
unless you're going to a really good
natural food store,
you're probably inundated with that
stuff.
If you go to the regular vons and just
walked down the aisle,
man,
you're going to get hit with so much of
this shit.
Right?
And it,
it's um,
it's interesting because the folks that
make these foods,
they study neurophysiology,
they study evolutionary biology,
they study how to make things addictive.
So it's,
it's kind of funny.
On the one hand were like the
gatekeepers,
the medical establishment.
A lot of the media,
if you talk about like this ancestral
health template or what have you there,
there's still a bunch of like pissing
match and contention around that.
Whereas the people who are making these
foods addictive,
they fully get it,
but they're using it in such a way that
they're like,
okay,
here's our predilection to eat more and
move less.
Here's how we're going to make that
happen and we have these really
interesting flavor combinations and
different experiences and do,
do you want to,
do you want to run that,
that video.
So here's a really interesting example
of this,
um,
where,
you know,
you could get bored of even a really
tasty food,
but then you can figure out a way to
bypass this whole process.
Strategy works for now.
And I resumed my epic ice cream.
Okay.
So what,
what's going on there?
Is it Andrew Zimmerman?
Uh,
or no?
Adam.
Rick manned a man versus food he does.
He's eating challenges and he's in this
thing called the kitchen sink challenge.
It's an eight pound ice cream sundae and
I think anybody would,
would say that an ice cream sundae is
pretty tasty,
you know,
and it's hyper palatable like it would
make you want to eat it.
But what happens to him is he gets
completely bogged down in this process
and can't go on until he orders a plate
of extra salty,
extra crunchy french fries.
So he's actually gagging on the ice
cream.
Can't go on,
he's not going to win this thing and the
way that he gets out of this situation
is by eating more food.
He would not have finished the sunday
were it not for eating the french fries
and so you have this situation where in
are woven into our genetics is this
process called palate fatigue where even
if we have a really tasty food in front
of us we will get bored of it and then
we'll want something else and if you
have that other thing that something
else immediately available and it's
different enough from the thing that you
just got bored with,
you can eat more in total and it's just
so interesting.
Like he would have failed eating this
ice cream sundae.
We're just the sunday,
but not only did he eat the sunday,
he ate probably about 1500 calories of
extra salty,
extra crunchy french fries.
How did he know that?
Soon?
Explained that to them.
So if you go to professional eating
websites,
like people who go do these things where
they like eat hot dogs and whatever.
Yeah,
competitive eater.
There are pairings.
So it's like,
okay,
so with hot dogs you need something like
gummy bears because the hot dogs are
salty and media new mommy,
so you need something kind of sweet and
fruity and light.
And so there are all these pairings that
you do.
And so with ice cream,
because it's cold,
creamy,
sweet,
the perfect compliment to it is this
salty,
crunchy umami that you get out of the,
uh,
the french fries.
That's fascinating.
You know,
I've always found that if I'm eating,
I'm eating something and it's really
good,
like a steak or something.
And um,
I,
I'm stuffed even if I don't want any
more of the steak.
If I have fries and I taste those salty
fries,
I'll start eating more fries.
Like I know I'm full,
right?
Am I stuffing my fat face with these
stupid fries?
It's,
it's that novelty.
And from an evolutionary biology
perspective,
it's great wiring.
It's great engineering because we didn't
have guaranteed food all the time.
You know,
like you had to eat when you could get
it and then,
you know,
you might go a long period of time
without having that food.
But now we're in a situation where you
have infinite variety,
there's 50,000
different food items in an average
supermarket is 10 or 11,000
new food type items that are released
each year.
They're engineered to be hyper palatable
to bypass the neuro regulation of
appetite and it's super easy to just go
fill up your pantry with a wide
assortment of these things.
So then you can do what,
what he ended up doing here.
You can eat one meal,
you know,
like man,
a little sweet thing would be really
good.
So you have that sweet thing and then,
gosh,
a little salty crunchy would be nice.
And so you have the salty,
crunchy and you can just keep eating
through this whole process.
And it really makes most of the standard
like dietetics recommendation of,
you know,
eat less,
move more,
everything in moderation.
There's no moderation in that
environment.
It doesn't exist.
It's a hookers and cocaine experience,
you know,
I mean,
it's like these things spin the dopamine
centers in the brain,
they are addictive and,
and,
uh,
and if we are surprised by that process
at all or feel bad about it,
it's kind of crazy.
Like it is not your fault if you find
yourself in trapped in this world of
hyper palatable foods.
And I don't suggest that people just
roll over and expose her belly to the
world and let you know,
let the world have its way with you.
But understand what,
what,
why it's so difficult.
Like you should not feel guilt.
There shouldn't be any drama.
There should be no morality around it.
Like if we just understand this is your
basic biological wiring and if you
understand that and it's not your fault,
but let's do something,
then we can at least decouple ourselves
from the emotionality and the drama and
the guilt that we've had around this.
And we can start making some changes.
But so many times,
the reason why I've heard from people
that they peel out of some sort of a new
way of eating or lifestyle is it they're
motoring long.
They seem to be doing well and then
they're like,
the,
they're just gone and then you talk to
them and they're like,
oh,
it's just hard.
It's like,
yeah,
it is hard.
But it wasn't just that,
it was hard.
They usually start getting some sort of
internal dialogue where,
well,
I suck.
I must be weak.
I can't do it.
It's easier for that guy than it is for
me.
So they bail on it.
And when I,
when I started putting this kind of spin
of this evolutionary biology and this
neuro regulation of appetite into
working with people,
particularly people who had had
difficulties with eating over the long
haul and maybe like some,
you know,
we're relationships with food or what
have you.
There was like this light that went on
there.
Like,
okay,
so it's not my fault.
I'm like,
no man,
it's not your fault.
We still need to do something and it's
not necessarily going to be easy,
but we can do this and if you aren't
beating yourself up about the fact that
this thing is a difficult process,
then we're going to be able to get a lot
further down the road.
Are there any foods that when you do go
off the rails,
like say if you have a cheat day and you
have a,
oh my god man,
eat a whole pizza and a bowl of
spaghetti and some fucking ice cream.
Is there any foods that can counter
balance the damaging effects or the
addictive properties?
Because the worst thing you want to do
is have a cheat day and go,
oh,
fuck it.
I'm just going to be a slob right now to
enjoy a cheat day.
By the way,
you know,
it's,
um,
don't,
you know,
and I,
I,
um,
so instead of calling it a cheat day,
I usually just say,
kick your heels up to whatever you want
to do.
I've seen a little problem when people
set it up and they're like,
okay,
saturdays are my cheat days.
And then you start gearing up towards
saturday,
it's like a heroin user who get the box
out and they flip it open and they're
getting all their gear setup and that
anticipatory process for most of these
people is better than actually having
the thing and that anticipatory process
is getting the dopamine,
you know,
go on in the brain and it just gets you
all wound up and do it.
So ideally,
you know,
let's say people eat three days,
three meals a day,
seven days a week,
it's 21 meals,
let's just say 19 of those meals are
pretty on point and two of them are kind
of kick your heels up to whatever and do
it whenever you want to do it.
The caveat to that is are there things
that are going to flip you out and
you're not going to come back from it,
you know?
And it depends if it's really an
individual thing.
So it could be a heroine food out there
as well.
So my heroine food is a
sea salt and vinegar potato chips.
Oh I love those.
Yeah.
Like kind of healthy though is vinegar
is potatoes.
Potatoes,
salt,
what's bad about them?
Well,
when you eat like a five pound bag of
them,
which I can do in the blink of an eye.
Then how big is a five pound bag of
potato chips are pretty goddamn.
Lots of leaf seizures,
but that would be a big site bag.
Okay.
Let let,
let's say,
let's say a 16 ounce bag of potato
chips,
but 16 ounce bag.
What kind of a slob or you?
That's crazy.
That time slot,
you know it's so,
you know.
Whereas my wife,
she'll eat a little bit of potato chips
but she's more of a sweets person
whereas I'll have a little bit of dark
chocolate,
but literally a good brick of dark
chocolate will sit in the cabinet for a
month and I'll chip away at it.
A block here,
a block there.
But if we have potato chips in the
house,
I will eat all of them.
I'm a dark chocolate and peanut butter
dude.
Okay.
Yeah.
Dipped in dark chocolate and peanut
butter because you know you got your
chocolate in my peanut butter.
Remember those commercials and it tastes
delicious.
Guess what?
Reese's peanut butter cups can't fuck
with an actual candy bar and an actual
peanut butter.
That's way better.
Right?
Right.
Fucked up with that.
It's still a really good idea though.
They shouldn't have.
They shouldn't have done it.
And that's why they stopped doing that
commercial because people said
[inaudible],
I'm just going buy a chocolate bar and a
big ass tub of peanut butter and have a
party.
Right.
It's way better.
But you know,
in that,
that's an interesting to like thinking
about the palatability thing,
how much chocolate can you by itself,
right?
How much peanut butter can eat by
itself,
but together together you can fuck them
up.
Yeah.
In ghirardelli's chocolate,
like one of those big ass thick
chocolate bars.
Oh right.
And,
and it's,
you know,
for me,
I'm not trying to moralize it or say
this is right or that's wrong,
but just being aware that like stacking
those flavor combinations,
like in general,
if you can make your meals enjoyable but
not over the top to the,
to the point that you're,
you're,
you're overdoing it.
And it's just different for everybody.
You know,
they have,
that sounds like you're saying enjoy it,
but don't enjoy it too much.
That's pretty much it.
It,
yeah.
But what about someone who wants to
enjoy it?
What about someone who wants to have
that delicious taste of the sea salt and
vinegar and the potato chips.
What I recommend is generally you have
that out of the house and you don't have
it hanging out in your pantry because
you go to the woods.
Like remember when we used to find porn,
we're porn the woods.
You to bring potato chips in the woods,
eat them in a dangerous environment.
So you're constantly looking over your
shoulder for wolves and shit.
Right.
That's a good strategy.
I was thinking more just kinda like go
to the mini mart and you get it in your
car.
But yet that god made me feel like a
real junk.
And you're in a bad neighborhood
shooting up in the parking lot.
Oh yeah.
So for you it's just that that's a.
That seems like a good healthy heroin
food though as far as like heroin foods.
I mean it's just a potato,
a root vegetable.
But I mean you can really track blood
sugar on it when you eat a bag of,
you know,
like the sea salt and vinegar,
potato chips.
My blood sugar was like diabetic levels.
So yeah,
it's have weird dance.
Yeah,
I would like to check it.
Yeah.
That's squared away with a cgm if you
want to do that.
It's continuous blood glucose monitor.
You put it on and it has it doing it,
doing it through your skin.
It's a little tiny hair,
hair size probe that goes through the
skin and then it samples the blood,
the interstitial fluid once a minute for
the duration that you have this thing on
usually where two or three weeks.
And.
And uh,
yeah I was using one of those ketone
monitors where you have to cut yourself
and then.
But it doesn't make me bleed because I
have too many cows.
His hands.
So it stick it in the fingers and my,
my fingertip skin is too thick so I'd
have to go to the side of my hand.
it's fucking gross to like jab myself
and the side and my fingers.
Right.
They've got annoyed by it.
This is pretty mellow.
I was even able to roll with it.
I just took some rock tape and put over
it.
Yeah,
it's a,
you know,
like a 50 fifty cent piece kind of deal
with low profile,
flat rolled with it on your body.
What if someone put you in like a bicep
crusher on that arm?
That would have sucked.
So yeah.
So what we're doing tap out before it
gets to that.
That one did not come up during.
Where do you put it?
Usually right there.
It's right where I'd get you look for
that spot.
I know he's got that thing on and real
fucking attack that thing.
That's so funny for me,
man.
It's linguine with clams.
That's my heroine food.
I love linguine with clams.
Is there any benefit to having gluten
free linguine versus regular linguine?
Definitely.
If you're reactive to gluten then yeah,
it seems to me just seems like my body
processes it a little easier.
Right.
But it doesn't seem as satisfying
either.
Hm.
Huh.
And it's been prepped pretty much the
same way.
It's just like,
it's a little less substantial.
There's like,
there's something about like real in
gleaning from a good italian restaurant
where has that aldente bite to it?
Right.
Hard to get that with gluten free pasta.
I mean there's a,
there's a textural element to it.
There's clearly a flavor element to it.
I'm gluten is just really interesting,
like the type of protein that it is,
it,
this is why it makes pasta and pastries
and everything so unique.
Like we don't make pastries out of corn
because it sucks as a medium like that
for tortillas.
So bad for tortillas,
but You're not going to make like a
sandwich out of it.
Yeah.
So I mean you've got those flavor
elements and then for some people they
do get a little bit of an opiate
response off of wheat.
So for you,
you have a tremendous intolerance to
wheat,
so you cannot fuck with that.
But for the average person that doesn't
have this tremendous intolerance,
is there a benefit to eating sprouted
bread over regular bread?
I would say generally,
yes.
Based.
Not necessarily nutrient,
but potentially this inflammatory
process.
Yeah.
And,
and again,
the enzymes,
the enzymes break down the gliadins and
so in,
in part it's just partially digested so
it's easier to digest and absorb to the
degree that there some problems with
like glee,
addon,
wheat germ agglutinin those proteins get
broken down.
So I would say that there's a lower
likelihood of those foods being
proinflammatory.
So if somebody's like,
dude,
I want a sandwich.
Then doing the zika or bread and,
and doing it on that to me would be a
pretty good wing compared to doing like
wonder bread.
Now is there any nutritional properties?
Are benefits to eating that bread?
Is that,
is there anything like you could say
like I'm eating something good.
The fact that it's a whole grain and it
hasn't been super denuded and process,
you're gonna have more b vitamins.
You could have more mineral.
So in general,
like if we were to weigh out equally,
you know,
say 100 grams of this hundred grams of
that.
There's gonna be more vitamins,
minerals,
antioxidants,
and the zucchini bread than in the white
bread.
Even though the white bread gets
enriched with iron and some b vitamins,
I would say that the bread is still
probably a win.
I never bought that enriched shit.
Right.
Rich flower.
Like why enriching it?
What are you doing?
Because it's because without that then
you get super,
super sick.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
Is that why they enrich it?
Yeah.
Because there were a nutrient deficiency
diseases like,
you know,
19 twenties,
19 thirties as,
as we really started industrializing the
food system and you know,
and there's,
there's a good argument for changing
wheat flour to white flour when you
remove that protein and fatty element
that's in the whole wheat flour,
it goes rancid much faster.
So white flour is much more shelf
stable.
It lasts a lot and also it has a
different flavor profile and
everything's a little more mild.
But there's a good argument again,
but you know,
it's like that,
that shelf stability thing,
this is part of the hallmark of
something that's maybe not a great
option other than chicharrones teacher.
Rene's could last a million years and
they're still amazing.
But uh,
there is an exception to everything,
but you know,
there was economic and pallet incentives
for why you would want to make this
white flour.
But it also,
people started getting more nutrient
deficiencies because the amount of b
vitamins and whatnot that usually come
in that whole grain where were gone.
That makes sense.
The zucchini bread is notoriously poor
as far as like shelf life.
Yeah.
It gets moldy.
Like almost immediately.
Yeah.
Really building fridge and all that.
That's one of the few breads that I
always keep in the fridge.
But.
So it's not necessarily good for you
though.
It's better for you then say a process
wheat bread,
but it's not really good for you.
I'm going to take those.
No,
I don't know.
I mean that's a really good question.
I've never really thought about it like
that.
You know,
like is a blueberry good for you?
You as a piece of steak?
Good for you.
Yeah.
I don't know,
like you again.
So if we did a nutrient density kind of
story and we looked that as equal brag
compared to good types of fruit,
vegetables,
squash,
I think that the equal bread would look
pretty skinny.
Like if you had 100 calories of this
versus 100 calories of these.
But again,
we looked at the vitamins,
minerals,
antioxidants that both of them had.
I don't think the is eql bread would be
a real rock star,
but I bet it would be better than white
rice.
It would probably be as good or on par
with something like lentils or something
like that.
Again,
as far as vitamins,
minerals,
antioxidants,
all that stuff.
So that's weird to me because I would
think that lentils would be vitamin
rich.
Not huge,
but they're not terrible either.
I mean it's just all this kind of
relative thing.
and you know,
rhonda patrick is really good about this
stuff.
She's really geeked out on what are the
most nutrient dense foods out there and
trying to really make an emphasis of of
eating those.
And so like sprouts tend to be at the
topic list.
And then interestingly,
things like organ meats are super high
up on the list and,
and,
and it starts kind of stratifying our
herbs and spices tend to be off the
richter high in nutrient density,
but we tend to not eat a ton of them,
but you know,
like ginger and basil and garlic and all
those things are really,
really nutrient dense and they also seem
to have medicinal qualities and
antimicrobial quality.
So there's some interesting stuff there,
but,
you know,
at the end of the day,
um,
you know,
you could,
people do try to do it.
It's like every meal is going to be
blueberries and the,
you know,
wild caught deep water fish and you
know,
a mountain of greens in and god love you
for doing that I guess.
But you know,
every meal does not have to be that way
to be pretty damn healthy.
And,
and you know all that.
So that's where the is equal bread.
I think that's probably not like a
terrible.
By no means is it a terrible option in
the story.
so it's not a terrible option,
but it's not necessarily the most
nutrient dense than you can eat.
Right,
right,
right.
Yeah.
Now getting back to what I asked
earlier,
is there a food that you would recommend
for a guy who did eat that one pound bag
of potato chips?
Is there anything or is it fasting maybe
the best?
Yes,
that's the best option.
Yeah.
I mean something like that or just you
know,
some period of,
of less intake and so,
you know,
but then that gets like,
I hear people screaming like,
you know,
disordered eating now,
I was like,
oh,
it's food,
you know,
a,
a eating disorder.
How does fasting considered an eating
disorder?
It's not eating and eating disorders
seems to me to be like maybe so many
bulemia start associating with low like
anorexia it and potentially the bulemia
dna.
Sick people don't fast.
That's what's,
they just don't eat right.
Um,
well it's interesting again,
like the,
the only thing.
So you could eat like a cockroach,
like you could walk into a work
environment or you know,
like post your photos on instagram.
About eating,
having a big,
big gulp and donuts and all this other
fucked up stuff.
And most dietitians won't really bat an
eye at that.
They're like,
yeah,
you should eat better,
but they're not gonna say anything.
But if you post some stuff about a low
carb paleo kind of look and deal than
you're a disorder dieter.
Or if you eat gluten free,
then they call it disordered eating.
Intermittent fasting is being called
disordered eating.
But,
but who is it being called it by
generally like the dietetics,
healthcare,
you know,
kind of mainstream.
Like I get a sale by these people all
the time.
And the intermittent fasting thing is
really fascinating because again,
for just a very brief historical step
back,
it's like,
have humans always had three meals a day
and most people don't even eat just
three meals a day.
They just eat all day long,
you know?
And,
and,
uh,
and there some clear problems with that
from an implementation standpoint.
They've done some studies where they had
people eat a caloric restricted diet,
which should be anti inflammatory,
but the one group of calorie restricted
folks eat consistently throughout the
day and they don't get that
antiinflammatory benefit because they're
just constantly keeping their digestive
system going and all that type of stuff.
So,
you know,
there's some really,
really strong evidence and suggestion
that some sort of punctuated eating
pattern would be really healthy,
but it,
it's,
uh,
it,
it's interesting.
On the one hand,
it's being really aggressively
researched in the kind of cutting edge,
uh,
communities like rhonda,
Patrick valter,
longo,
dom talks about this stuff a lot,
but then when you get into kind of thiS
mainstream dietetics story,
they're just freaked out by this stuff.
Like they really can't wrap their heads
saying people probably aren't even
freaked out about those lap bands.
Those.
Right.
This is disgusting bands that they put
around people's stomachs.
What do they call them?
Black bands,
right?
Yeah.
I saw some guy arguing for a vegan diet
and then I found out that he was a
surgeon that performed stomach shrinking
operations.
Yeah,
yeah.
Uh,
yeah,
like what the fUck band are you trying
to get people healthy?
Are you just trying to make money?
Right.
That's great.
We'll with some Folks is the only option
bullshit.
It's never the only option.
Does your mouth work?
Do your hands.
Where Can you put food in your mouth?
Then?
It's not the only option to and
disempowering people or saying that it's
the only option for some folks to get
them healthy.
That is insanity.
You are coddling them to the point of
you're,
you're willing to diminish their,
their overall physical structure of
their digestive system.
I mean,
that's what you're doing,
right?
I've read some horrendous things about
the consequences of these stomach
mineralization,
uh,
activities or the surgeries rather.
It's really scary stuff.
You have to completely limit what you
eat from now on.
Your stomach is about the size of my
fist.
Now it's this little tiny thing and you
get full quicker.
So that's the psychological mechanism
behind it.
You get full quicker and,
but,
uh,
the rabbit.
So the interesting thing is almost
immediately when people undergo these
procedures,
if they were like a type two diabetic,
like they come out of it and they're no
longer a type two diabetic,
almost immediately,
like it's really,
really interesting.
So there's that upside.
But then also the longterm,
you know,
two years,
three years,
four years,
almost inevitably they get themselves
back into the situation they were in.
And part of what's interesting is
because they have such a small stomach,
they can't hardly eat anything.
So there's a tendency towards eating
more refined food because that,
that's,
you know,
they,
they just can't eat that much.
So it's um,
I know a guy broke his out.
Oh really?
Oh wow.
He got a stomach shrunk,
got an operation.
She's a big fat guy and got a stomach
cut and then broke it out and had to go
and get a second surgery.
YeaH,
it's a,
that's where I'm very glad I didn't go
into medicine specifically.
Like that's just such a quagmire.
I would probably shoot myself being in
it.
Get infuriated when someone says that
that's the only option.
For some people that is not true.
That is just absolutely not true.
There are always options if you have
willpower of you,
have a mind.
If you have a support system,
if you have people that can coach you,
if you're willing to listen,
if you're willing to understand and
believe the consequences of your
actions,
you can change your diet and your
behavior.
You can,
and it doesn't matter if you're 600
pounds or 60 pounds overweight,
86 pounds overweight,
you can make changes.
it,
it's interesting because insurance will
reimburse for these like lap band,
gastric bypass surgeries and they're 30,
$40,000
to,
to pump people through it,
but it's really difficult to get them to
reimburse like a gym membership,
a health coach,
you know,
that type of stuff.
Which,
which um,
well it's got to be some collusion
between the healthcare providers and the
medical industry.
I mean,
just to dylan,
that's the only thing that makes sense
or that people demand it so much so they
can't deny it from people.
Right.
It's just very,
very frustrating for me when you tell
people that they don't have any other
options and that this is the best
options to cut you open and cut your
stomach and stitch it back to a smaller
version of it.
Didn't have what it is.
Well,
it end.
Did you see that thing wheRe they now
have a stomach pump where you can,
they,
they basically put a tube in there,
you can eat the food and then pump the
food out of the stomach and this thing
is awaiting fda approval.
So they stay in roman times.
This is where like,
you know,
the,
uh,
bread and circus just keep everybody
entertained and that old,
the whole thing collapses.
But they used to have the vomitorium
where people would eat.
Do you know tHat?
That's not true.
Really?
Yeah.
Not only is it not true vomitorium
doesn't mean that we.
What vomitorium means,
it's the entrance and exit to an arena.
The volley.
Yes.
This is something that I've gone into in
great detail and I went to the colosseum
in rome and they explained the
vomitorium and it's just a misdemeanor.
You're crushing.
My head shouldn't be saying that this is
crushing.
My whole,
like rome
fell work in a fall.
These guys used to throw up and now
we're doing it.
They may have done that.
They may have thrown up,
but it wasn't that a vomitorium
vomitorium is here.
Pull it up jamie.
So he could see what a vomitorium is.
What a vomitorium is,
is the actual structure of an arena like
where the people come out and go through
this area and it has nothing to do with
the word vomit.
Okay.
How am I going to tell them?
My post apocalyptic story about rome got
fucked heading.
That sort of vomitorium is okay,
but how do I tell the fucked up?
You should have googled it,
man.
dude,
you should've done a.
We did.
You fucked up.
You tried to pass away some some
bullshit man up.
So chagrined.
But.
But it's important because I read a lot
of people telling me that and educated
people like yourself have said that it's
just not true.
Okay.
That's what a go back to that image of
assist.
Yeah.
This,
these vomitorium exist in every arena.
That's what they are.
The stairways come down and then that
opening at the bottom of the stairway,
that is a vomitorium,
but what is the origin of the word?
Now?
They threw up,
they threw up.
A few of them did really rich people.
They wanted to eat and keep eating.
They threw up,
but that's not what it is.
Like go larger please.
So I can see that his series of interest
is or exit pastures in ancient roman
amphitheater or theater.
A place where which according to popular
misconception,
the ancient romans were supposed to have
vomited during fees to make room for
more food.
Not true.
THere you go.
Damn.
Sorry dude.
Oh man.
It's important that you know about it
that I am properly chagrin thing.
Yeah.
It's just one of those things that
people repeat and then they never
bothered looking it up.
Um,
would that pump though?
Go back to that fucking disgusting
stomach pump.
This is so nasty.
So this is a high.
I'm fat and my brain is stupid and I
just love to eat so I can eat now and
yay.
Eat normal healthy meals.
Hey,
that girl in the middle is triggered,
I can tell,
and then you stick this pump through a
fucking hole in your belly button and it
sucks out the food because nothing could
go wrong.
Look at that.
Look at her for honey.
Go outside,
go running.
Stop.
Look at me.
I put the food in my mouth and it sends
a signal to my brain.
It's a simple procedure.
Low risk,
completely reversible.
Takes just 15 minutes.
How about fuck you?
Twilight sedation back in home and just
a couple of hours.
Look at that cartoon,
the cartoon people like that girl needs
it.
That girl's hot as fuck.
She's skinny.
Even cartoon hot.
This is ridiculous.
You don't need it,
honey.
Stop.
Well,
I think this is her afterwards.
Oh,
that's her.
This is all these people that have
shrunk down from having.
When I go back to that,
go back to that.
Here's the thing folks,
all you people that have benefited from
it,
you could do another thing.
You could just change your diet and one
of the most powerful benefits of the key
to genic died.
His appetite suppression and that
appetite suppression is fantastic.
It's amazing.
Even for a person like me who's never
really struggled with their weight,
I find that going without food is not
only is it easy,
but it's really inconsequential.
It's not an issue at all.
I can go without for five,
six hours,
you know,
it doesn't bother me at all.
Yeah.
It's um,
it's super liberating and you know,
the tooth,
it's powerful as it is.
It can also be where people get
themselves in trouble.
A lot of the problems that are ascribed
to just low carb I think is an outgrowth
of it being so satiating that you under
eat.
So if you are hypo caloric for too
often,
too long,
the net can be a big problem.
I don't have issues with that.
I eat like a pig,
but.
Right.
Um,
but I've definitely lost weight by
changing my diet to that ketogenic diet.
And I've met so many people on the
roads.
So many people want a mountain about
that come up to me and they say,
thank you.
I've lost 60 pounds.
Thank you.
I've lost 80 pounds.
I've changed my diet,
I drink kale shakes in the morning,
and now my body is just a completely
different thing and it just feels
different.
It works better.
So important,
man.
It's just so important to take care of
this meat vehicle that you're driving
around.
It's so many people are falling prey to
that supermarket line of cans with shiny
colors on the labels and you get roped
into this idea that just because you put
it in your mouth,
it's food and your body is just sludge.
It's just slugged down with all this
nonsense
in a ketogenic diet is interesting.
Some people that seem to never really be
able to get anything else to work.
It's possible they may have some damage
to the hypothalamus,
the energy regulating centers of the
brain.
It's unclear what's going on,
but we we know that a key to genic diet,
it has some really great benefits for
neurological conditions in general like
epilepsy.
Some parkinson's alzheimer's research
that's going on and conditions are
conditions,
but it's possible that these ketones may
be altering to the physiology of the
hypothalamus in such a way that we get
normal energy regulation of metabolism
and appetite.
More importantly,
cognitive benefits as well.
It's another thing when people don't
have that lazy,
foggy feeling after meals,
right,
and that foggy feeling is pretty
substantial and really important.
If you're someone who has to think for a
living that's hopefully is most most
people hopefully I think in some way,
but you know your brain running on
ketones,
that's the one of the things that people
are always scared about.
Like,
oh man,
your.
Your brain runs on sugar.
Sugar.
You need glucose to run your brain.
That's not really true.
Right?
Right.
In again,
like 70,
80 percent of the brain tends to shift
to just ketone body metabolism.
When you're fully keto adapted,
there's still some of the brain that's
going to run on glucose.
There's some red blood cells that are
going to run on glucose,
but the.
The interesting thing though is that you
just have.
If you just look at blood glucose over
time,
there's a pretty cool
a guy went on a medically supervised
fast for 382 days and you look at his
blood glucose levels and is beta
hydroxybutyrate levels and whatnot.
Do that.
He just drank water.
He drank water,
had some electrolytes.
Day 382 days stay alive.
I don't even understand the fat.
What that was.
This guy that.
Yeah,
it should have a picture of the guy when
he,
when you track it down,
if it was over 400 pounds,
he went from over 400,
I think,
close to 500 pounds.
Down to 180 pounds.
I think he finished off like 180 pounds.
Guy didn't eat for 382 days.
Didn't poop for almost two months.
Whoa.
He fat.
Hold on.
He fasted for over a year and somehow
lived.
How far can you go without risking your
health?
Whoa.
Is there a before and after photos of
this gentleman?
This is it.
It was,
um,
if you go to this and just go to,
the images,
then you'll probably see like a,
a yeah,
go to images and then we'll have
something with the beta hydroxy.
I'm not seeing it.
Huh?
That's incredible.
Imagine if you knew this guy and you
didn't see him for a year.
Could you throw ketosis in there also?
S
amazing if you did a fifth one over
that.
Yep.
Nope,
that one right there.
Yep.
So blood glucose,
free fatty acids and ketone body levels
during his fast.
So his blood glucose,
that second from the top line,
the triangles that dropped and then was
just rock solid beta hydroxybutyrate,
which is that,
that,
um,
the main ketone body that,
that gets used as a fuel substrate that
goes up to a pretty high level higher
than what you would get under a
nutritional ketosis typically because
this is a starvation deal.
Free fatty acids elevate a cdot acetate,
elevates a cdot acetate,
kind of interconvert to with the beta
hydroxy butyrate.
But what's interesting to your point
about the mental state,
if we were graphing someone's blood
glucose over time for this period of 40
days and they were eating normal mixed
meals,
that thing would be seesawing all over
the place,
understand how he has any glucose
because gluconeogenesis in the liver,
so he's he even eating a hunter like
absolutely no carbohydrate at all.
There was a glycerol backbone of fat
that can get converted into glucose and
then also certain amino acids which are
gluconeogenic can get converted into
glucose and so the body will use those
because we still need like just making
dna,
the pentose phosphate pathway.
We need some glucose to be able to do
that.
So like cellular replication and
whatnot.
But you can do that with effectively no
carb.
So without dietary glucose,
the body converts fat to glucose,
some of the backbone of fat,
the glycerol part,
and then also proteins.
Yeah,
but with this guy,
it's not even proteins unless his body's
eating his meat,
which they probably did to some degree,
but this is part of the benefit of
ketosis is that it really reduces the
breakdown of lean body mass,
but if you think about it like there are
people who end up with these huge,
you know,
folds of skin that need to get it
surgically removed.
There was a pretty good argument that
had they used a fasting protocol instead
of like a low fat higher protein
protocol.
If that protein is still being supplied
in the diet,
then even though the fat goes away,
you still have the protein matrix of the
skin and the interstitial.
A connective tissue that isn't going to
go away,
but when we're more in that fasted state
or intermittent fasting or maybe
ketosis,
the body is turning over that protein
base and that's really important.
That's this apoptotic process,
but you could potentially have a
scenario where people who are losing a
lot of weight if they use these fasting
protocols,
aren't going to need that cosmetic
surgery at the end to get rid of these
sales.
Of.
Of skin,
is that possible?
Is that really possible?
Yeah,
but has anyone done it?
I mean,
it's anecdotal at this point,
so if they've done this,
why don't they do well,
what happened to this gentleman?
Well,
this guy looked totally normal.
That's the thing.
I mean he was huge and then it looked
totally normal.
You didn't have ridiculous lose fat,
right?
Flying squirrels skin.
Right.
Whereas like a lot of the people that
you saw in like the biggest loser,
like they,
they had that stuff and they were using
a higher carb,
moderate protein kind of deal.
Sorry to interrupt.
Does your body have the ability to
understand that the skin that's hanging
loose is not necessarily.
Yes.
Yeah.
Just kind of mechanical receptors.
This piezoelectric effect effective
feedback of all that.
Yeah.
What about people that have lost all the
weight in another fashion and now
they've gotten to them themselves into
this really thin body with all this
extra skin?
Could they go on a fasting protocol then
and would the body absorb that skin
tissue first before it started eating up
the muscle tissue height?
Possibly,
but the challenge with that is it
because they've already decrease their
fat mass,
like are they now leading this into an
unhealthy state?
So what,
what if they decided,
let me fatten up again,
like maybe the move would be to fatten
up again and get yourself obese again
and then go on this.
I meAn you're laughing,
but honestly wouldn't that be the move
to get yourself fat again and then going
on a fasting like this guy's monitoring
medical medically monitored fasting and
then your body would absorb the fat
again and the skin tissue.
Maybe I would.
Maybe.
It's interesting.
I would have never thought about doing
that.
I would maybe think about like two or
three days a week of fasting,
so some intermittent fasting and then
you get into some normal eating and then
even what you could do is you could go a
two or three days of fasting or a very
low calorie intake and then at the end
of that period you could just be very
low protein and then maybe four out of
the five days,
four out of seven days your low protein
and two or three of those days you're
super low calorie.
What have you tried that and it didn't
work.
You still got that floppy skin.
Then it would suck.
You'd be driving and this guy might have
it nailed.
Yeah,
yeah.
Fuck,
you got to get fat again.
Folks,
don't get the surgery.
Just get fat again.
Don't say that to people though.
It's hard to say because nobody wants to
do that because it's so hard to lose
that weight.
Right?
Once you lost that kind of so,
but when people do get that operation,
when they cut their skin and it's really
dangerous,
super dangerous.
There's a high risk of infection,
a high bleeding.
Yeah,
yeah,
I mean it's horrendous.
Yeah.
It doesn't.
Usually finnish guy who got attacked
with a knife or something,
you know,
covered in these das of sorts.
Yeah,
yeah.
Score,
score scars or either you have a book
out.
Yeah.
That's the book wired to eat.
Was it about.
It's about the neuro regulation of
appetite.
Oh,
well we've been talking about a bunch of
it.
Yeah.
So I mean a bunch of the stuff like the
uh,
the ice cream deal,
like I talk about that stuff in the
book.
Um,
it's,
you know,
it's steeped in this evolutionary
medicine perspective,
but I'm really,
if I'm effective with this,
I'm really trying to decouple people are
like unpack all the emotionality that
they've got around food.
Like if they've found challenges around
changing their diet and lifestyle,
it shouldn't be a surprise and it's not
their fault,
but at the same time I don't want them
to just roll over and give up.
Like we,
we've got ways to move them through a
process of discovering what works for
them,
what doesn't work for them and we can
move her forward.
But I would say like 50,
60 percent of the people that end up
failing in this process,
it's kind of emotional baggage type
stuff and also there's this sense.
So when people are at jujitsu and
they're like,
man,
this shit's really hard.
It's like,
yeah,
if you want to keep doing it then do it.
But it's,
it's hard.
It's always hard.
And similarly,
doing diet and lifestyle changes
frequently is pretty difficult.
And so if you can just understand that
and understand that that's normal and
you're not beating yourself up about
that process,
that we really stand a much better
chance of turning that corner and making
these effective,
longstanding changes.
All right,
so the book is out right now,
right now.
Rob wolf.
Then get it to amazon.
I'll anywhere books are sold.
Yep.
Alright dude.
Well thank you very much for being here.
Thank you for having great,
sweet robb wolf,
ladies and gentlemen.
All right,
this show's over.
Go do something else.
Bye.
Love you.